two hello everybody happy Friday it is
October 7th
spooky month spooky month is coming up
here all right only a couple weeks away
uh thank you everyone for being here
today's episode
is sponsored by hellofresh
so ninja loves specifically
listen guys
the kids are back in school and you can
get back on budget hellofresh is 25 less
expensive than getting takeout and it's
even cheaper than grocery shopping gets
65 off plus free shipping with code h3tv
65 at hellofresh.com
h3tv65 and you know what's funny about
that this isn't part of the ad this is
just content now but yeah show how
delicious that is okay
now you know how we've criticized AB the
burrito you're wearing glasses today
it's Friday baby
bad ass thanks man
um
we always criticizing AB for his hello
fresh vids I don't know about
criticizing but well the burrito one but
then he made a burger one and we were I
don't know if you were here we were
doing oh tell me more about that
yeah and you took like one little photo
of the burger yeah I didn't show you
what was inside and I immediately messed
I immediately you said hey does this
look good and I immediately messaged him
back I said hey can you get more
close-ups and he's like I already I
already ate it yeah I'm very impatient
yeah so he he did a make good for us
yeah he has finally made something
Worthy
of hellofresh's delicious and again this
isn't even part of the ad this is just
love of the game here yeah
say beer
deliver
chopping those potatoes oh yeah wait
that's Lina
it's a collab at first okay oh my God
wow
[Music]
this thing is like 200
I thought you're talking about the video
I'm like okay yeah I got notes
I'll give you some notes after the show
okay yeah but there it is baby is
bringing it
he's getting serious now yeah can you do
me a favor though and help me yeah yeah
yeah move that back yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like back where
it was
distracting thank you
also a little quick shout out
I love the burger video I don't know if
they got enough of a moment here yeah I
really didn't get a moment I'm sorry
because I I my focus turned to this but
it was really good everybody loved it I
mean yeah
most of all hella fresh I will be
invoicing you guys for an extra spot
just so you know that's fine uh yeah
thank you
also just a quick thank you to um
new drop to teddyfresh.com check out
this the world is [__] frankly
have fun well you can which is what this
shirt says
now check this out we got Dan actually
showing The Classy zip up sweater
cardigan Dan you you might not have that
card again and I love it on then you
want to show it you want to stand up
maybe
I know it's a kind of a schlep there in
the Scorpion sure yeah thank you bud Dan
please play I can't tell if I like it
better on Dan or better on Lena right
Elena you had to go there okay you had
to go there but I'll show you my fit too
she's lying oh my goodness let's go
thanks baby yeah did you guys was that
just an accident that you guys lined up
so Dan wanted to wear this shirt and
then he came he's like oh are we really
matching and then he got that one and I
didn't tell him Lena was wearing that
because she wasn't here to do anything
he didn't say anything yep Dan I think
you gotta wear this every day really
yeah I love it yeah be upgrade too Lena
you know what I love it though I'm glad
we're matching he doesn't seem too happy
about it but I'm I'm really excited
because you're upstaging me again
you guys are all wearing the blue ones
but the brown one has this beautiful
pink trim yeah you do so beautiful okay
checkers
that's fine thank you nobody's wearing
this one actually which is
so one of my faves yeah cam really
wanted this one but uh I think we're all
out of samples of this one um I gotta
get one for cam yeah
um other than that we got uh Ian in the
tug of war Polo sweater I'm actually
gonna know oh that was camshaft cam
which I also love too and I'm frozen but
yo hold on looked great yeah it looks
great yeah
hold on you're just radiating forecast I
don't know four cams okay what happened
to Cam's Camp I I was feeling myself so
much in this that I took a selfie this
morning so I dropped that in Discord oh
we got a cell so it looks like we're
getting one frame per minute there
so if you check Discord I uh okay
okay the full look Discord uh was closed
on my computer
I will need to go to the page lots of
prep for it oh my God Cameron okay King
it really completes the uh the look damn
damn
Island on there it's it looks oh wait no
my camera's back so here we go damn the
dog look
yeah this is a good look bro yeah it's
beautiful thank you very much watch out
people of the world
spice up your life Cameron's on the
prowl even in one frame per minute it
looks great and then Ian you're wearing
the beautiful polo shirt is that right
uh yes that's right yes look at that
crawler look at the it's very dark but
you know it looks nice it's classy it's
nice
it's very comfortable
nice hear it is rocking the uh
this thermal this bow is too tight
I love it it's very soft and I love a
waffle shirt I love waffle shirts we're
working on some really cool waffle
shirts right now that are going to come
out next year oh my God I'm staying
tuned
very nice Olivia thank you everybody was
uh listening
Sam are you roughing something yeah I am
oh yes
yes one eight seven seven Ted is that a
real number do we decide or no it is and
Sam is wearing it like a dress which I
really like yes what size did you go for
I am wearing a large as a dress cool oh
my goodness uh fashionable Queen what
happens if they call the number I
remember we were thinking about doing
something but I don't remember I think
they can leave a voicemail uh I don't
know if we're doing anything with them
no guarantee that we'll check it but
apparently your voice can be heard in
fact I'm almost certain we will never
check those thank you
um just being real
uh Zach is wearing the the reaper the
reaper tea yeah that's my fave bro I
love this [__] that one sold out
yesterday I was so surprised though I'm
gonna look into a restock
that's what suits you because you're
badass just like this shirt thanks
brother appreciate badass [__]
appreciate that and then AB is wearing
the other one that's sold out which kind
of was awesome and surprised me but
there it is
the world is [__] have fun while you
can ain't that the truth right baby
that's right I'm sorry buddy
um the shirt that I'm wearing for me is
like I love it it's inspired from a lot
of vintage shirts that I have
um and we created this original artwork
of teddy bears
I just think it's super cute Mr Peanut
just commented on our live what's going
on here yeah the uh in our baby room
live
yeah talking about baby baby night wait
you talking about baby nuts Planters
brand Mr Peanut put some respect on his
name well he's team nut now wait what
did he say you're making a peanut tear
up if only I had an actual tear duct
um
goat man what do you want from me Mr
Peanut maybe I'll chase her maybe hold
on hold on guys
wait we love peanuts I love I love baby
nuts they should sponsor us yeah no
they're they're getting free are they
gonna pay us if they got free
sponsorship like us they're talking
about their dumb asses
I'm about to stick my dick in that jar
boy I like my friend from Tick Tock you
know what I'm saying
good man
no but peanut guy do you want something
I mean reach out we'll hook up peanut
peanut up
right we're friends no idea who is Mr
Peanut you don't know Mr Peanut it's
iconic uh marketing capitalist Pig
it's there's a Mr Peanut brand [__]
monocle I think I'll show you when you
talk about baby oh okay yeah I've seen
that yeah they make great by the way
people gonna think this is like a some
kind of slick integration I wish I was
getting paid for this yeah Planters
that's what it is
Mr Fina is uh it's kind of weird looking
it's odd yeah it's for sure odd I mean
peanuts are that one is cute though and
uh that's baby nut baby no dude we are
we are fans of baby not in this office
well I got bad news for you guys baby
nut is a garyvee invention yeah I know
he had a funny idea he's not cute
anymore well his idea was that whole
Super Bowl thing where like he dies in
his reborn baby peanut I don't know and
became team nut and now he's
Mr Peanut now he's clutches oh he says
uh peanuts and love peanuts and love oh
fan of the show Mr Peanut well he was
it's a little bit of a lag so let's see
uh Warren nuts Warren nuts yeah Mr
peanuts reach out I'll take I'll do
whatever you want just pay me
it's getting hard to follow our
conversation so you guys are saying
peanuts and love and I'm like
yeah what are we talking about and then
I realized
loves the nuts yeah so ela's um Ila's is
um
where's yours here it is oh is that
yours yeah the Oxford Oxford stripe
shirt
I'm wearing the nothing of value inside
embroidered tea
let the world know
and there is also a real version of that
one yeah it's it hits too close to home
doesn't it
um
uh where is it
oh here it is
and that's about it I mean I that's
that's what we're all wearing there's a
lot of really cool accessories too
there's the beanie which I think you
would like cam for some reason because
there's like a critter on it
there's like a little critter on the
front yeah
and then about love I guess we are not
sending product to Sweden that's a
little bit of a delay unfortunately yeah
we everything we do here is like by the
skin of our teeth so I don't think we
have it we'll try yeah I'd love to try I
guess I get a lot of stuff I'm thankful
by the way the beanie I'm wearing is the
stone wash beanie which is super nice
there it is that's enough thank you
thank you to everybody
welcome Mila
thank you with the wet look the hair is
making me wet
okay
you making my p word wet ass
I'd like to talk about that more let's
put a let's put a nut in it for later
gay my boy
I'm not in it yeah I don't know oh we're
gonna do magic
are we in your bedroom
I'm playing cards today I'm doing some
gambling [__] [__] yeah wait
really are you playing by you're
gambling by yourself solitaire
[Music]
wait I missed some words
Gabe are you playing Solitaire by
yourself
gambling yep
that's super interesting so
okay and what do you stand to win
and so well have you heard of this game
show called card sharks where you have
to bet which one is higher or lower yeah
yeah
okay okay cool man seems like a
thrilling Friday you're having there
baby [__] yeah
so you're in your room what's going on
over there something nothing interesting
by the sound of it
because when I'm by myself yes they
walked in this and with your soul on the
line right you need to focus hard man
let's do one for us
let's see the board
so there's a two and a
two what do you say higher or lower it's
got to be higher right how could it be
lower
of course hey all right wow you're good
at this dude and then do we do the eight
or the queen now
you want to change the eight you want to
make it an easier card
uh what no what's your do I do the eight
or the queen
you wanna do the queen okay let's do the
queen it's got to be lower right I mean
it lower it's got to be yes oh
wow only higher than the two am I right
Gabe
oh you're about to own Gabe's Soul it's
got I'm about to own your soul game you
better be sweating it's got to be lower
than the king
oh my God are you freaking
kidding me dude it's got to be higher
than three
oh wait what happens now
if it's a tie it counts that's a loss oh
you [__] suck dude
what's the chance of pulling a three on
a three
all right you get to keep your soul for
now
people are yeah baby people are angry
that we're promoting gambling
[Laughter]
Gabe listen um
it's Friday baby so I just want to say
[__] Yeah
tits in my [__] eyeballs [__]
ball [__] [__] yeah
shave off my head and shove it up my
butthole baby
all right
I'm hand put it around my butt oh it's
like a wreath
I love that hey Gabe what are you doing
for Halloween anything fun
um we're gonna probably get a um
are you gonna you're gonna scare people
that sounds fun baby [__] yeah baby
collect some money from the
from the Halloween people by scaring
them you just give me my give me some
money or you're gonna die whoa it sounds
like armed robbery that is scary
that's a real Halloween right there it's
scary
for sure [__] [__] my [__] [__] on my
toes [__]
how about this one I'm a [__] in your
gas tank baby
okay the gas tank and
that's a mess up your mess up your fuel
lines and imagine yo imagine you take a
dump in someone's fuel tank or like the
part where you put the hose in and then
they go to fill up the gas and then Boop
there's a piece of there's a bunch of
[__] in there
[Laughter]
I'd be wild huh I'll be your wireless
I'm really gonna mess with someone can't
start the car now that's the repair
that's a Halloween spook right there huh
yeah the repair bill of the mechanic am
I right that's the real Spirit that's
the spoon right there yeah
absolutely all right yeah baby listen
you can you keep up on Solitaire there I
know you're
I know you're you're viciously uh at War
and so I just wish you all the luck on
that game and I hope that you win
[Music]
wishes baby [__] La Vista hasta la vista
[Applause]
see you later [__] back baby
see you later
oh [__]
all right thanks Gabe have a great
weekend
all right always good to hear from you
take care buddy again next week buddy
take care
[Applause]
Oh Oh It's Friday baby that's good boy
club Gabe One of a Kind always a
pleasure White Cloud Gabe you can
support him you can follow him on all
social medias and Cameo uh for your
mom's birthday or whoever's loved ones
in your life if you recently had a loved
one that passed away perhaps he gave my
Cameo sorry about your dad
I'm saying that one I mean what better
opportunity than that it would cheer me
up
I wonder if he could run a discount on
like a funeral cameos like a suspect or
maybe like two for one if both your
parents died oh my God okay stop I'm
just saying it's a good marketing angle
yeah so we were talking about Eli's wet
look oh baby talk to me and this super
crunchy yeah that's a secret
really everyone knows it's crunchy no no
just it doesn't matter if it's crunchy
it's wet it actually no it looks amazing
thank you reminds me The Fifth Element
dude that's like art
you look like a Fifth Element stewardess
which is the highest
not a stewardess but that's the highest
compliment I can pay because all those
ever all the women in that
movie are
crazy well-dressed and super high thank
you I love that movie I love that movie
yeah now you look great tell me about
your procedure how did you get ready the
procedure yeah I'm sure it was right
it was lots of gel and a lot of [__] ton
of hairspray really how long did it take
like 30 minutes of
all of that
worth it and how much I wonder how much
product you use like how many times
could you style your hair like that
I feel like it's probably gonna be gross
tomorrow
but you probably um it's fine but I I
just watched it like it was wet yeah it
was wet that's why I just like sprayed
and gel and all that stuff that's kind
of the dream to be honest because when I
was I had my hair long I would say
in like high school middle school I was
whenever it was wet I was like this
looks great right I love this look and
then by lunchtime comes around and I
look in the mirror and it's so [__] up
holy [__] what happened this looks good
compared to that because if someone has
a brush I can show you what it actually
look like it's it was frizzy and it
happens to me sometimes
to this day you know sometimes I don't
blow dry or do anything because I don't
have always time for that oh look at my
hair and I leave the house thinking like
it looks pretty okay and then halfway
through the day it's just like
I think you always look I think your
hair always looks great thank you
because I know there's some people who
are like
extremely gifted and beautiful they they
think that they see these little details
about themselves but you always look
great to me I think your hair always
looks great right now you think this
looks great I love it
I just look unkempt how I'm I'm the host
of the my biggest podcast in the world
I mean what do you guys think about his
hair I think you have nicer honestly you
think your hairline has a big
uh is a big factor in it but also the
color yeah okay yeah your color is nice
you have beautiful hair it just needs a
little
little TLC you know I've never found a
dew or a hairdresser or Cutter that
makes it really good for me it's always
just like it looks good maybe for a day
though you never want to get a haircut
yeah they're a curly girl yeah hair
stylist I need a curly Stones yeah
do you see this you know my hair changed
a lot I feel like as I got older right
it used to be a lot more frizzy and froy
but here I'm gonna try my best to show
you guys are you brushing it like that
it was giving us volume it's gone crazy
volume like I would show up I'd be like
oh my hair looks good today what I'll be
being up to the girls I like how you
doing talk to me and then I go to
go up to the bathroom at recess look at
this [__] I go oh my God
and then I hide my head for the rest of
the day I hate my hair thank you yeah of
course I'll do the whole episode like
this
yeah this one's pretty this one is
pretty iconic of what my hair looks like
I was just gonna clean this yeah this
was Love's profile picture for a long
time and anytime I would text message
love this is how I imagined
you like that you like that dude love I
love that I'm also growing my hair on
right now that's why I've been wearing a
beanie for like two months well let me
see don't hide it from us I mean it's
super super horrible hold on let me
it's like oh wow oh my goodness
beautiful hair club
damn bro give us that cold steel
blue steel blue steel oh oh wow
demonetize the episode just now gone
sexual over too hot
um so I think you should keep growing it
out it's cool growing it out more
uh anyway to what end it doesn't ever
fall what I'm saying that's awesome
again in high school I grew it out it
was so far it came down to my chin like
this and it does not fall but that's so
cool how is that cool it looks pretty
you got the fro man it's the science
hair that's cool Einstein here
[Music]
that's so cool dad what about what about
the dreadlocks
what about a mullet
that's that I know Jeff's gonna try to
give me a bullet when I go on a show and
I just I don't know that's not you yeah
if he gives me a mullet I'm gonna cut it
the minute I get home I'll be upfront
with them I see Jeff listen not doing
the mullet
that's one thing I can't ever do but
again my mullet would just be like kind
of like the broccoli assassin people are
saying you should do a poll how about
your hair
it just there's my hair is not moldable
it Just Puffs in the back
what do you I think the fact that it
defies gravity is like
huge plus I think most people would want
that so what what do you do with it
actually though that's what I don't
understand
you don't do that okay step one I would
kind of do the opposite it looks like an
onion dude go back to how you started
today really revert River
and three one sometimes when I wear a
beanie for a long time watch if I wear
this beanie for like 20 minutes and take
it off it'll look better just need some
pressure like some pressure cook hot pot
I think you should go blonde again
or do like some kind of fun color like
some kind of crazy color ninja red what
was the color ninja used to always go
blue ninja blue I'm Coming For You ninja
you know it's crazy a lot of people go
through a lot to get their hair your
color because like the Platinum was in
and then like mine yeah yours yeah oh I
would die for like yeah yeah because
it's not Oh you mean the gray yeah the
gray yeah yeah
because it's not like purely white it's
you know you still have like dark
undertones old man listen you guys can
tell me all day long how much you love
my hair so I just dedicated to your hair
listen at the end of the day if you had
this [__] hair you would hate it too
trust me you know the Grass Is Always
Greener is what I'm hearing right and
you all walk around with beautiful hair
except Dan of course which we love he's
a he's a bold bald man and we love that
above
bold
bold bald and beautiful that is
beautiful thank you
anyway uh you look great deal I love the
look
oh yes that's what I'm feeling oh my God
how did you guys do that that's what I'm
that actually looks pretty fire what do
you guys think wait can we I think
can we see a light pink I know ninja did
Red you could probably pull that that
looks
I feel like
bright colors have been done too much by
YouTubers like a lavender might be
pretty oh yeah
what about yellow the lavender is yo
what about cheddar yellow
um I love it
going on
I'm feeling excited about the left
well anyway
um
regardless I'm gonna put this back on
um so let's see we did all this we
obviously you guys seen the title of the
episode everyone's wondering what the
[__] going on probably
it is Frenemies all over again
[Music]
there's a huge development
in the Frenemies hellscape
and I will tell you right after this
break no I'm kidding
there's actually no more breaks we did
all of our ads
should we talk about this now or should
we maybe and stay tuned for the
Frenemies updates
shout out members BTS number 40 is up
thank you AB thank you also shout out
members
the fans only uh members only podcast is
up from Tuesday
thanks for having you next Tuesday wait
is this what I really looked like
yeah that's not that is not better
that was those aren't certified lover
boy haircuts what happened there I don't
remember
we tried to shave a heart into them oh
yeah
very successful
look how happy I looked though to be rid
of all that air man
[Laughter]
all right enough about my hair God damn
it all right I just got another image
[__]
yeah I mean what do you think
you guys who you tell me who did it
better
this is
for sure Jonah but Drake I can't get
over the fact that Drake actually walked
around like this what is that is that
crazy I can't get over the fact that
Drake just walks around
right I have enough of him his ass
should stay indoors
there's that one guy I think he was just
doing this as a meme but he did cut it
short with the heart but with the this
wig I think this was just wasn't he
rocking this haircut for a minute he was
rocking it like shape like yours he did
both I thought yeah for
I think I think this was just a social
media post I don't think he was actually
walking around like this maybe the
dracologist
I'm sure that is a real discipline of
study
also I want to thank uh orange who said
I felt Worth or no
bus to Bacca what's the name Justin Baca
why does it say orange though because
the sheet that I copied it from it
includes the uh their color on YouTube
for some reason
I felt worthless I felt worth it I felt
ugly I felt ugly I felt good okay I felt
that oh no that's just based on what
they told me they told me
thank you Justin twenty dollars a pop
yeah
[Applause]
dude dude that has got to be the best
moment in YouTube history it just makes
me so happy how did we not know about it
before that's such a good question like
what happened on the Streamys which you
you have a lot of hostility too so I
doubt that you watched the streamies to
well it was a keemstar thing right we
found it what during the Vlogs he did I
think the first appearance was when we
were doing the um steamy Awards and
worst award show was the streamies and
then that clip showed up I said and we
were all like what just crazy it is yeah
[__] good man
he tries to cover his ass so hard it's
just such an it bro he [__] up so bad
such an underground meme oh my God not
anymore girl
by the way someone said Ann said Ethan
what are your thoughts on one punch man
season three that didn't come out did it
I would have heard if that came out I
don't know that can't be it right are
there only two out there's two seasons
yeah season three release date August
18th they announced that almost it's
officially happening almost three years
after the second yeah yeah yeah yeah I
know it's happening I'm super excited
are you [__] kidding me bro I'm
excited dope this is [__] bro
that's for me right now
also Housewives a lot is going on I
don't know if anybody cares
what's going on housewives I'm vaguely
aware of all this because Ali watches
all of them so I'm always like hearing
it in the background so the Beverly
Hills ladies it's all picking up I've
been waiting the whole season to see
what happens with Kathy Hilton because
they teased it in the very beginning so
it's finally happened so Paris Hilton's
mom is in this show and she is cuckoo
she is [__] but she's awesome a lot
of marbles but she's awesome and fun to
watch didn't something happen with Lisa
Rinna too Lisa arena is the worst person
bro she's the worst and she's causing
all the drama and she's always acting
like she doesn't know what's the problem
steering the pot and now Kathy is going
head on head with her
it's insane so so next episode is going
to be the reunion it's going to be oh
yeah you guys should watch that even if
you don't watch I will when is that it's
on Wednesday okay
but the crazy thing is like Kathy Hilton
who
buy off all estimates is worth hundreds
of millions of dollars
gotten a huge bitter argument
because one of the ladies went to a bar
Lisa Arena went to a bar and ordered
Kenner Kendall Jenner Jenners 818
tequila okay hold up let's go back a
little so Kathy was trying to promote
her daughter's tequila brand now a lot
of them always promote their product
whatever it is so nobody was giving her
the moment she wanted she was like let's
everybody drink my tequila and nobody
would pay attention and then they were
at the bar and Lisa Arena was like I'm
gonna order my friend Kendall Jenner's
818 together it was clearly done listen
I'm gonna defend Lisa I think she she
said I'd never tried it and I just
wanted to try it she took one shot I
didn't think it was that big of a deal
and Kathy Hilton at all
she knew what she was doing are you
serious
when you're on absolutely yeah when
you're on a show that's consumed by so
many people you're aware of the fact
that well she should have just kept
their mouth shut anyway these women are
insane how they like bicker and complain
and the [__] they say so then if you go
to to um the one my favorite by far I
don't care what anyone says is Salt Lake
City yes one of the girls
in between seasons
she had a hot mic moment with her
alleged best friend who's on the show
with her and she went in the bathroom
and she goes that [__] [__] [__]
she [__] half of New York she's
cheating on her husband she has a family
and kids and she's like she's a [__]
she [__] all of New York dude
friends for 10 years 10 years friends
what the I need to get on there so
obviously the show leaks it and now
there's like this huge [__] oh my God
it's so good and she's trying to pretend
like it wasn't that big of a deal and
like it was psychotic dude so this shows
are back to back it's Beverly Hills and
then Salt Lake ladies it's like
Wednesday is on fire right Andy Cohen
it's incredible yeah I know this is
probably boring to a lot of people don't
follow but men it's a it's it's top
level oh and with Salt Lake City they
have Jen Shaw who is already pleaded
guilty but when they recorded the show
that didn't happen yet so the whole show
she's like I'm the a victim dude she was
she's awaiting trial and we're just
watching it like you pleaded guilty we
know it no she's about to go to jail for
15 years legit like part of her bleed
deal was that she can't get myself to
less than like 12 years or more than 12
years 15 years
so the whole time this this bee is going
around can I say B yeah okay I think we
said you can oh [__] just go for it oh
the [__] conversation go in
she was raided by the [__] FBI during
an episode
and for all these years she's opulently
Rich insanely decadently rich and oh
nobody really understood where it came
from
this woman it turns out was scamming old
people she was generating leads from old
people and working with someone else to
scam and defraud old people
millions of dollars she's
the one with the most money too and
nobody knows how
like bottom of the barrel [__] up
crimes and so now she's awaiting trial
and she's like oh I'm so innocent this
is all shut up I don't side with Lisa
mandio I hate Lisa I'm just saying no
he's gonna hate Lisa I'm just saying in
the bar scene I thought okay whatever
one housewife at a time yeah we're it's
it's hard okay
Salt Lake first so so this whole time
she's like I'm innocent this is all
[__] I'm being framed whatever blah
blah blah she's like the bullying that I
get every day crying I wouldn't be here
today if I didn't have like basically
saying she's thinking about killing
herself
she's not she's not she's just she's
trying to get sympathy but it turns out
I think that the FBI or the government
just had such an insane case against her
stop saying scripted you're [__] she's
going to jail
about it Erica Jane just had to return
her 1.5 million dollar earrings that she
was hoarding because the government said
yo you got to give that to the victims
[__]
who's worse Erica or or
Erica yeah she's a nightmare she's a
literal villain we got to move on guys
I will talk about this later I'm just I
just want to say I hope Lisa arena is
gonna be kicked off the show this season
I think Erica really needs to get kicked
off she she doesn't she's just honestly
this villain she's disgusting she's
basically a criminal uh she has she's
just a vile vile person it's super
entertaining The Watcher but like she's
so despicable of a person I don't think
she deserves the Limelight or the
attention ugly you're disgusting I'm
gonna kill you okay I was like uh oh
I gotta move on because I can't talk
about this [__] there's too many people
that don't know what we're talking about
I prefer really not to
not to speak thank you if I speak I am
in in big trouble yes in big trouble and
I don't want to be in big trouble yeah
we should Tuesday about Housewives oh
now that's a good idea okay this to you
next Tuesday I'm gonna talk all about
the housewives you can catch it all
there that's the members only podcast
yeah we just lost members by the way
uh there's one don't know I missed where
is it the one from the beginning
Michael said just join shout out to
Jillian and Jason thank you very good
happy wedding anniversary
all right we got a lot to get to all
right one of my favorite things we got
to talk about today is we got cav-cav's
dating profile from Raya this is a
[__] Rye yet
we have agents everywhere dude we do we
have infiltrators there is a fupa
Trooper who saw Ryan Kavanaugh on Riot
if you guys don't ride it's a it's like
Tinder for celebrities high profile
people
and uh how do you get on that I think
it's like invite only right oh really
it's it's like invite or you can apply
and they have like a council I think
a council
crazy what but they just look at your
profile
I think they probably look at follower
accounts and stuff like that they run
your credit yeah
basically put your credit score on your
profile yeah
and so oh that's where the Ben Affleck
meme comes from that was from Raya it's
me no really why'd you unmatch me it's
me it's me why did you unmatch me
you know the story on that I kind of
this girl unmatched him on Ryan for some
reason because she thought it was a fake
yeah right and then he sent her a
message on Instagram going
get your [__] together bro
you didn't even talk to her why you so
why you so enthusiastic your walls been
right
so uh Hassan had it and matched with
Cara the model
oh yeah his I think she never got back
to him but Hassan's on Raya damn
uh
anyway
Jesus Christ I can't focus today
so a fan saw Ryan cavan on Raya
and she's like oh my God it's Cav cab
I'm gonna swipe yes even though he's a
wild pig
he maxed her because she's probably
matching yes on everyone
that's the only way that guy gets any
interest first hand experience yeah he's
he's been using one hand for too long if
you know what I mean well Brad the bull
absolutely [__] railed his wife
yeah anyway
um
good guy that Ryan Kavanaugh anyway
so she mashed him he started messaging
her and she she couldn't respond she
couldn't bring herself to respond now we
have to protect her identity
because if they find out she leaked any
info off the app she'll get booted but I
think we're safe because yeah she gave
us she saw the the censored version she
said yeah all good that the council will
come after her if they find out what
she's doing
the good the good thing is that Ryan is
probably just messaging and he's so
desperate how could he keep track of who
he's messaging stuff and he probably his
pick his opening line was so bad you
guys
uh here you know what maybe I should
just go to that and then we'll do the
Frenemies thing after because I'm
already in so deep
Ethan when we talk about Housewives we
have to talk about somebody else what
what are your thoughts on the charity
homeless not Toothless
that was such a funny moment you missed
it wait I missed that what does that
mean we're gonna have to watch it and
talk about it
uh Cody says Ethan I've been dying to
see a live reaction this new Trump goof
okay is this the n-word one no remember
going to say it's going to use an
expression we have to keep our country
gate
holy [__] what's going on here bro there
is something in the water out there
[Applause]
yo they got a [__] ad for coins right
next to this of course they do yo you
guys get your free Trump silver coin
text Trump to 98998-99 Silver Coin it's
like the ultimate like grifter lib
libertarian scam
it holds its value you bury it in your
yard I don't really know
okay I gotta watch that again [__] God
remember I was going to say
expression we have to keep our country
gay people but it's not I mean for some
reason
oh [__] that was so good
wait that's not a gay man wait hold up
hold on let's compare him to fousey real
fast yeah it's the fumble
get hit me with the Jack I felt gay
fumble is perfect I felt that no didn't
like that
okay wait I should use an expression we
have it but
I thought no like that just based on
what they told me
yo thank you so much yeah shout out Cody
that was so much I will pull that that
was so much fun wow tremendous
yeah uh oh [__] so back to Cav cab so
let's open without further Ado Ryan
Cavanaugh's
Raya account so if any actually if
anyone's on Ryan they're looking for a
celebrity corrupt and competent
businessman who's a literally a super
mean and hideous
has yellow teeth this could be your guy
big meanie
let's take a look oh it's a video this
is what she sent us yep
so you probably want to pause as you go
yeah it's important to see some of this
stuff
dude she is such a queen
the first message he sent his opening
line was
go-to karaoke song
cool
which makes me think the first thing I
think is oh this guy's an alcoholic
drink a lot of alcohol on the first day
that's what he's saying
that was his first message to him he
said karaoke song
you serious yeah yeah that was it um
oh this is his profile
listen to this he goes Grammy Emmy Tony
Oscar Academy Nom when [__] you never
been dominated for a Tony Award right
that's gotta be a lie
what was he nominated for you could go
to his Wikipedia and see it's probably
just one of the films he produced but
well Tony's for stage yeah for theater
oh yeah I meant the other ones maybe he
maybe Finance some play at some point
maybe well hold on his life is kind of
like a Greek tragedy so maybe
he thought well my life is like a play
therefore I got a Tony
he does have a Grammy
okay
Shadows what did he get a Grammy for
Best music and film it's a team of three
others because he's the producer I guess
so he gets a cut of that wow he didn't
do [__] shots
and then so he says Emmy Tony Oscar
[__] you ain't got no [__] Oscar
shut up
and then he said I've actually I mean
that one makes the most sense because he
was a film producer yeah but he didn't
want to Oscar
Natalie Portman because the early on
relativity was making like fairly
prestigious movies right before that it
they started doing like cowboys and his
Cowboys and Aliens and [__] his official
website says that he his films received
over 60 Oscar nominations and eight wins
really maybe he's including all of the
Marvel movies that he uh launched
you know what good for you man that
makes it even more crazy that you're
actually bankrupted that company right
it's incredible
uh he says horses dogs helicopters
archery physics you think this guy does
physics
this guy does is how to ferment [__]
sugar into alcohol actually more
precisely how to just drink it that's
physics I guess that's so cringe from
horses dogs to helicopters
he's just trying to flex I don't think
he can afford helicopters anymore when
he was the uh when he was the owner of
Relativity there's a story about how he
used to take a helicopter to and from
work yeah
and he used to land the helicopter at
his house and his neighbors called the
police because it was so disruptive and
insane the police made him stop it was
actually illegal great guy horses dogs
helicopters archery [__] you ain't no
[__] Robin Hood
there's no shot this guy knows how to
shoot a bow more like little John maybe
a stick you could hit people with little
John was dope I'm not even gonna put
that on you why are you hating on Little
John and a few other obsessions like me
maybe like suing people yeah
it's like four now I guess you would
call that an obsession
he goes consider community service a
privilege and family always first you
fake donated to who Habitat for Humanity
a million dollars that should be in your
profile not
service is a privilege
service is a community service a
privilege
yeah can we unpack that Mike hey what is
that
he's saying that I am a huge uh you know
philanthropist
yeah it sounds like he's like it's a
privilege if I were to do it it sounds
like I'm doing you a favor yeah he's
saying I'm in this extraordinary
privileged position as a rich guy like
to fake give people money I am so
privileged to give it's good community
service court ordered yeah right court
order doesn't count bro
yeah and also when he says family first
I guess he's talking about his wife's
pleasure because she's [__] a huge
jacked Israeli dude
bread the bowl that's family first I
think they got separated or divorced now
Brad
no Brad's probably stolen the picture
just Ryan's not
which is even funnier once you see his
pictures uh coming up later in this
video so Dylan I would [__] Brad the
bull that guy is good looking and sharp
his body he's got a good honed body
you think Brad the ball
I understand the show I'm watching the
show yeah by the way L.A County Sheriff
probes Ryan Kavanaugh over reported
helicopter use yeah so this is 2013
during his Heyday yes sir we may have
interrupted this Manhunt by landing on
the sheriff's helipad oh this story this
ended up yeah it did this doesn't have
that much legs to it well I remember
relativity media spokesperson called the
investigation a politically motivated
Vendetta sure Ryan yeah
a rift between Ryan Cavanaugh and the LA
County Sheriff office has widened
they dropped the charges it ended up
being nothing
yeah probably pretended to donate to the
police Union
so yeah he oh he lives in Bel Air
neighbor
uh going down oh it's a video [__]
let's see here uh oh yeah his favorite
songs are so crazy dude fit Ryan's
mixtape come over now we can't play that
maybe you can sing it for me it's like
the corniest [__] music okay his
profile song the one that's supposed to
Define him is hilarious oh this one
right here Chasing Cars yeah because it
made me think of like this is what he's
probably playing while he's getting cuts
are so funny if I just lay here as I
just lay here is the chorus he's just
laying in the corner as I just lay here
death song they played that like four
different times for four different
important steps
yeah and Idol gives back American Idol
when they went to Africa and helped
people with malaria that is the song
that they always sing
I'm just laying here in the corner with
my dick in my hand
Brad the bull is going to town on my
wife
I use my tears to masturbate it's not an
ideal Lube but I get it done
[Music]
life is such a tragedy
I don't think I know any of this
well it's all it's all like sad boy it's
all like subway stuff if you keep
playing it
um uh the video it opens up the playlist
and you can see quite a bit more I mean
there's there's some shape of you bro
unreasonably triggered and I'm frozen
again but just you know I love this
static internship Camp by the way here's
the line from his favorite song Chasing
Cars if I lay here if I just lay here
would you lie with me and just forget
the world
[Music]
sorry forget what we're told before we
get too old show me a garden that's
bursting into life all I am all I ever
was is here in your perfect eyes they're
all I can see I don't know where I'm
confused about how as well just it
didn't didn't really have for me the
dude is sad and cocked if you listen to
it you'll understand he's sad and cocked
yeah
I think if they ever make a biopic
that'd probably be the title huh yeah
setting cup by the way if you guys feel
bad for Ryan remember this guy is a
piece dude do I need to remind you
what a piece of [__] this guy is
hopefully not okay
I think we've made that pretty clear
yeah over the course of the show hey bro
you ever heard of the Saudi I ain't
talking diet code fake Nation well we
record we gonna always want to smoke oh
shout out to my homie and his name is
I ain't never gonna stop instant pot be
the best and shout out to the people
that be jealous okay so here here's his
ex-wife who's getting who's you know the
uh
yeah so the cowgirl so your first
picture on your dating profile is you
with your recently divorced wife oh my
God he's such a mess and what's so
obvious and pathetic is that he's
obviously just being like you see I've
dated I've been with the attractive
women before you can trust me yeah and
uh well that didn't go so well
I think he's been married several times
and
they've ever lasted
weird how that works
none of my business though this is like
the worst dating profile if I have to
guess what they normally look like I
mean yo look at his next photo Ela what
yeah
what is that what is that what am I
supposed to get from that
I don't know it's it looks photoshopped
like what's happening here he's badass
is it like Vietnam
uh moving on here he is oh this is this
one's my favorite It's a poster of him
with him holding a magazine cover with
it
ah if only this was like comedic but
it's not yeah this is totally this is
like comedic genius here yeah
holy [__] this is such an iconic photo
here
[Music]
um
Kailyn or I don't know if I'm saying it
right it's saying whenever I see other
women on a dating profile it's an
immediate left swipe like wouldn't that
be obvious
no nobody wants to see another woman on
your dating profile oh yeah it's like
baggage you're like I have baggage it
did not move on yeah I will and I will
become obsessed with you and not move on
yeah especially when they're like
clearly romantic photos like he's
holding her in a way that's not this is
my sister it's this is my way well maybe
it implies that he likes to get cocked
you know oh maybe he's into it you know
I see I feel like we could help honestly
Ryan if you are watching this
there is a lot of useful uh insights
into your dating profile here
okay hold the phone we got to go back a
little bit and there's a lot to unpack
here obviously but this is a photo where
are you in that photo in the chopper are
you is he trying to say that's my
helicopter I like helicopters he can't
even drive a car on his own huh
that's true
oh my God and remember guys if you start
feeling bad for a member that he lied
and said that his uh VP sexually
harassed someone completely fabricated
it just so he could fire him without
severance
pretty bad
also he sued me like three four times
now losing count l
sounds mean yeah he's a dick
what do you say about this one
is just so silly well cam actually had a
a funny theory about I I personally
think that he's in the Splash Zone and
I'm frozen again but that's okay
um he's in the Splash Zone of Brad the
bull
[__] Brad right there
if it's another secret message like I'm
into being cooked yo I know this is
really
I'm sorry this is really graphic and if
this is your thing there's nothing wrong
with it but I'm just wondering
if when Brad's done he finishes on cat's
face
in the splash though baby that's what
he's implying oh man you're right and
not that there's anything wrong with
that if that's what you're into like I
support you he gets right under Brad the
bull you know and just I just wondered
if that was what he's trying to say
oh [__] dude he loves the humiliation
and that's your thing that's fine yeah
there's a thing for everybody what was
what did you mention there love
oh your Mike's your mic's muted there I
love us talking about the deadline uh
for the payment
oh you know what oh yeah regarding if
you go to if you type Ryan Kavanaugh and
I love you should be good now sorry the
Google
um browser
you can go find Us website scroll down
where are we oh we're in third that's
good foreign
yeah the timer you'll notice that zero
he he of course or trailer owes me sixty
thousand nine hundred and sixty three
dollars and 49 cents
apparently the timer hasn't started yet
we're waiting for the judge to sign the
order or some technicality so when the
clock starts for real we'll restart the
the Doomsday timer there on Ryan kavikov
I wonder if like I know that I've seen
other creators
other people you can come to
unusual settlements
unusual
like I'll say this about keemstar that
I'm actually going to compliment
keemstar
when he got sued by like um Ace family
he goes I'll settle but you have to give
me your [__] million play button
because I keep starting to house two
people's play buttons as part of a
settlement
my point is is you could get creative so
I wonder if I didn't want to say this
I don't think I should say it get your
words straight Jack
I was at a creative solution I think
maybe it's too vulgar all right let's
not go there then I don't want them to
be in big trouble yeah here he is with
uh uh a celebrity
Jake Gyllenhaal areas with variety who
famously wrote an article he's suing
before
right
here he is the same picture of Jake him
and Mike Dylan Hall foreign
if you were a real person I agree that
would be a good first photo yeah
not a helicopter yeah man this is a real
dude more like this Kev oh okay wait
she's just
yeah I think it just goes back this one
is stuff that's his leading one can you
imagine how [__] bad that is Ryan you
gotta change that bro and this is from
Pure Love This is Love dude you've got
to change that photo what are you doing
how are people supposed to what are they
supposed to take away from this [__]
it's so stupid and bad
I just found the uh origin of uh
the black and white like
what do you call it helicopter photo oh
the modern Mogul Ryan Kavanaugh
did this photo makes no sense without
context yeah it is just bizarre he just
thinks he looks so very nice in that
picture
he's wearing like a leather trench coat
like you're about to get your balls
stomped and come down by the ball that
line is very accurate with what go back
to it said like Hollywood's economics
rule Hollywood economics the rules he
invented
not starting a business
or acting as the that's not his wife
it's an act oh she looks just like it
still looks romantic honestly okay
Bosworth wait are you sure it looks just
like his wife looks exact no but
everybody in the chat is saying wait
hold on okay okay wait hold on hold up
who do they say it is
Kate Bosworth Kate Bosworth dude I swear
to God
when you see a picture of his wife he
looks similar that does look she looks
that's her actually you know what okay
there are other photos yeah together
different
weird [__] okay yeah I just pulled up I
apologize to uh his his ex-wife looks
exactly like that dude I'm looking at a
picture of her that's crazy look at this
I just typed Ryan Kavanaugh's wife and
then this one came up oh that's the one
I'm looking at yeah wait who's a good
looking dude on the right that's Brad oh
that's Brad yeah and what's crazy is
he's wearing a matching hoodie with his
wife
um
by the way I didn't even look for this
this was the first thing that came up
when I typed Ryan Kavanaugh's wife Brad
the bull matching hoodies with his wife
I'm just saying man and then the second
one is this brutal bro the second one on
Ryan Cavanaugh wife is Brad the bull and
his wife having a pina colada
[Laughter]
like
if don't worry about seoing my [__] bro
you got to fix Google [__] on your
wife results bro it's another one here
write Kavanaugh's wife they're all
pictures of him or with Brad maybe he
set this up himself maybe he just likes
the Google remember they were they were
they were Partners first
the real estate Partners or some [__] uh
so she had an affair probably
we don't know that I said probably
could have been consensual you know like
he was okay with it that would make more
an arrangement yeah with what we know
about Ryan that makes a lot more sense
yeah oh this is crazy anyway uh you know
you know whatever
so there you have it uh
she hardered it and we love that for her
so friends on Raya there is
a huge opportunity there
by the way he should add this to his um
dating profile
I don't know yeah perfect the one with
the kiss would hit hard man them kissing
Harvey on the head yeah what is this one
this is
who is that
um
why did you guys why did you send this
one love
what what's happening
I was muted
why is that happening I don't know
what's going on with my
it's it's on my end he's not doing
anything wrong you're not doing anything
wrong love it's not your fault it's not
your fault okay oh there we go I just
like re-diggered my uh
go ahead yeah go ahead the the Ryan
Kavanaugh uh Harvey Weinstein thing go
back to the other one sure it's like
it's like a perfect [__] meme
in fact it's so funny he looks so left
out don't he yeah it's a [__] meme oh no
by the way just this oh oh no this is
the aftermath
did is that what just happened
oh they took that photo earlier in the
night man
does it again
that's why they call him Ryan bukaki
Kavanaugh he loves it he can't get
enough he's a little [__] [__]
[Laughter]
you just can't get enough
Ryan you naughty boy
I can't just get over what a [__]
beast Harvey Weinstein is like dudes
he's so fat and vile and disgusting not
like but his eyes are like shut he's an
orc yeah it only makes everything about
him worse yeah what I mean like yeah
he's got like a rotten dick and [__]
like just everything about him is so
disgusting to be honest I would love to
see his you want to see his running he's
one of those rotten jump looks like his
gangrene ass [__] [__] oh
God Lee gee will occurs bro she will
welcome
oh man you bust out the Old Timer yeah
speechless
oh so this is the messages he sent her
first he said go to carry go to
karaoke's karaoke song and then she she
didn't respond to anything so he
messaged her again oh he says we should
play tennis sometime are you any good
she told me she has
no interest in tennis never played
tennis nothing in her profile about
tennis just the least game any human
being has ever had and then by the way
he sent her a third message
he says I don't understand why girls on
this app match with others if they
aren't going to respond
no we didn't
oh and to god wow why did you unmatch me
dude
he's crying oh my God that's the game
he's like what was the problem not
enough helicopters
what can I do better it's such cuck
Behavior yeah yeah you know if Ryan was
just
a little less insecure I could help him
honestly I couldn't I could help him
make his profile really good I think he
would have a lot of women interested but
the way it is you have to be a [__]
loser I mean who opens with what's your
favorite karaoke song to begin with
yeah right I should mention e-man and
she also said
there was no mention of karaoke or
anything like that in your profile that
would have at least made it make some
sense like Snow Patrol what are your
thoughts on Snow Patrol you like
Counting Crows dude I got two tickets
and Counting Crows concerts at the
Morongo Casino
I guarantee you he's asking that
question for one because he can
overanalyze the song obviously and you
know talk off of that but also he's
gonna name drop whatever person they
mention oh that's so true yeah the what
he's gonna wait for them to mention a
song and then name drop that he knows oh
yeah I named the band Snow Patrol
I know I saw snow I'm like damn we're on
patrol man you know what's crazy oh you
like Counting Crows yeah well I said I
wanted to [__] a 14 year old Natalie
Portman
okay
oops can you read that last message
again he says I don't understand why
girls on this app match with others if
they aren't going to respond this emoji
it's sad wow
[__] that's super pathetic super and
so like yeah really sad yeah he's like a
billionaire and so with kids
two likes to get cut cringe cook
wait
he'd be like a vole cell though a bull
cell voluntary he's probably gonna mess
over next you're not even pretty
not real whatever I didn't even care
about you [__]
well there it is I understand why he's
so upset and why he's suing me and stuff
it all makes sense in context of like
his pathology which is obviously that of
someone very unwell
and uh I wish him well you know if you
want to talk about your profile even
though you're suing me because it's so
sad I honestly would help you I will
help you and I'll give you pointers
that's very gracious of you yeah I am
gracious
you hear that Ryan
do you think he's gonna see this I don't
even know probably not I think he's yeah
I will yeah I imagine yeah absolutely
he's gonna try to
start a new lawsuit probably you think
so he's gonna watch us after he's wiping
over leaking his Riya profile that would
be
that that would be the most pathetic
move all of human history before he
files that just change the first photo
just swap it out with it yeah anything
else well well it's part of posterity
now if he sues us it's entered into
exhibit already or he could change be a
changed man he's like you know what you
guys are right you know yeah thank you
for that I gotta switch it up a little
bit no seriously we could help you so
much
you know
it's a shame
it's a shame at the end the way it did
you know I could have been your Bryce
Hall
I could have been your Dixie demilio you
heard I was making movies with them oh I
know yeah he started a production
company called
what's it called um the quad
he's making he's trying to attract the
the high schoolers
oh see you know what I'm saying hang out
the quad the flip with the 14 year old
Natalie Portman he's working with only
Dixie Bryce Hall
and some other tick tockers and he's
putting them into and 50 Cent Oh and 50
50.
everyone wants to see 50 set in Dixie to
Millie on screen yeah
he's like trying to make it's gonna be
such a financial disaster man
I don't know he has any money to throw
at this kind of [__]
somebody else's money well there it is
um
uh shout out Ryan uh we wish you well
and uh I am magnanimous I am here with
open arms to help you to advise you and
to love you and the way your father
never did I will be I will give you that
nourishment
emotionally
and I'll come on your face if you want
if that I'll do that too not that I I
don't like to but I would if he asked
you do that for him because I want to
help him just because you're gracious
it's a gracious [__] not one of lust
in fact I'm not attracted to him at all
I wouldn't even you know it wouldn't
excite me in the least bit it's a
[__] of graciousness
of of of effect of Brotherly affection
that's what I [__] up to say but it is
what it is okay
foreign
okay I'm here for you bro this episode's
turning yellow
okay
well anyway so there you go yeah I
wouldn't be surprised after if he's
tried to sue us for this segment or
he'll try to he'll probably contact Raya
and be like you need to you need to do
something about this
to write an article
an opinion piece all right let's move on
to the Frenemies part um
it'll be fun I gotta go pee because I'm
hitting this game sub all right
so here we go at the same time or do we
take turns
okay we'll be right back all right
somebody just donated 20 euros and said
shout out to Ethan for scaring me into
seeing a dermatologist and saving my
life that's what I'm saying Bobby Lee
Bobby Lee that's what the [__] is up bro
I love you guys stay healthy everyone
yes I found your life and you only give
me 20 euros
dig deeper man
we appreciate the 20 euros thank you so
much don't don't listen to him Ethan
just pulled a foosie cake
did he what did he say I have no
recollection
um anyone here from Wisconsin so you
know usually when Ethan takes these
bathroom breaks we usually plug Zach's
show
if I can just take a moment to say I'll
be at twitchcon this week and I would
love to meet you guys I'll be there
Saturday and Sunday hopefully meet some
of you foot soldiers there peace and
love have a great time maybe thank you
buddy thank you guys just saying oh
Anthony and the old ball and chain Lena
I hope you have a greater time thank you
so much Cam I wish you were coming I
wish I could go and meet lean oh yeah
hell yeah I'm back at the bunny he's the
bunny this is this is my old stomping
grounds all right now baby you gotta all
right now Zach live at the uh the mint
January November January
what year is it dude that was like two
years ago the mint November 3rd the men
exactly the worst plug I've ever heard
at the Troubadour January 16th
I've literally plugged Zach's show in
the behind the scenes I think every
behind the scenes yeah they say the
right venue it's almost sold out so it's
almost sold out we're almost there
you're almost there you're gonna sell it
out buddy don't worry you're gonna sell
it January 13th live at the trigger good
old time I can't wait to get hammered
there yeah get come get [__] up again
watch me get cut off cut off at the bar
yeah
I the show I was going to tonight just
got canceled he uh he got covered attic
oh he did oh that's uh
Frick the guy yeah
he's a legendary sub Zach's family yeah
man do you want me to come play some
tunes take some photos for fifty dollars
Zach a lot of people are asking for you
to do the John Wayne Gacy voice at your
show ah John Wayne Gacy yeah they'll be
there man
he'll be there at the show he'll be
I'm gonna drink something about that
Pogo the Clown
Joker brain pogobrained Pogo brand so he
says shout out to Bobby leaves save me
from being financially ruined uh for not
getting my pool checked out from
Milwaukee Wisconsin yeah from Wisconsin
fellow native oh
Pop you know with some bears and take
some photographs for fifty dollars
Ela are you watching the Dahmer series
oh and that's when is this yeah it's
sort of God I started it and then
and then I was kind of creepy it's a
scary old time
happy Halloween everybody it is the day
I come out Jeff Dahmer
I'm just covering the dog some piece of
cheeseburger
oh yeah take your time
I'm glad you're doing fine and then the
minute I said it's dead air you want me
to keep doing the Dahmer voice
thank you brother all right now back to
your regularly scheduled program oh my
God okay I'm just gonna put this up
there if anyone wants to get creative
eat your heart out oh [__] you looking
for something to do this weekend feel
free to photoshop oh no you get sued for
providing a meme format no he'll try
we'll find out you know creative coming
out right there just sue Kim yeah can I
give up you might want to remove this
green bit here uh yeah I just did that I
can how can I what's the best way to
give a transparent background I don't
even know uh but why do you just why do
you want the green on his beard maybe
just make it white yeah just fill it in
yeah I'll make it white hold on make it
white Cam
just like come just yep just like bread
whoa here's a here's an interesting Dono
Brett says he's going to the front line
of Ukraine for the third time but I'll
be back for the live show holy wow wait
you're Canadian and you're going to the
front line of Ukraine how's that work
Brett
stay alive bro
Wait no that's not what I meant
just on his face make the green see the
greener on his face oh I see okay sorry
about that yeah yeah yeah you think
Brad's got like like a hefty load oh God
I mean judging by his face
all I'm saying is when that bull sees
that red hair you know he's unleashing
[Laughter]
you ever seen a bowl you know when they
breed in Cows and Bulls man you've seen
how they
they collect man oh yeah they definitely
do all right this is disgusting
yeah I don't want to talk about his load
side yeah
not that the rest of the conversations
or any cleaner but
okay here we go here guys here is the
final
uh
inspiration here it is guys Feast your
eyes have fun with coming together you
know what let's tweet that out love you
guys can get the
yep the full image on Twitter just have
fun to see what you got
yeah it is good luck on Raya Kev all
right come so
okay so here's what this Frenemy [__] is
about
all right
foreign
it is funny though it's a good story
it's a great story
full send podcast the milk boys
uh jerked off is the guy you give the
guys who jerked off his dog they've
really young kid Justice for Donnie
Donnie his doggy jerked off
and did you see Bradley Martin put out
yesterday we were talking or yeah
yesterday we talked about he put out a
video going like you guys actually
believe that
I haven't seen the show yet but I saw
you guys talk about it kind of so and
all the comments on it were like bro he
was serious like we didn't have to say
anything because we're their own fans
right
so the full uh send podcast nelk is
having their own five percent moment
[Music]
he takes that five percent
they are having some differences
astronauts absolutely and
um a dude there's a dude named Bob
mannery
who's known for making viral Sports
commentary parodies I've never heard of
this guy in my life
but he's doing a five percent on him and
it's turned into quite a bit of a drama
for them
jerk off Donnie yeah I mean I mean Steve
is [__] overshadowing the whole
Donnie scandal
oh is that what they're trying to hear
do you guys know who this is I never
heard of him but apparently he's popular
they gave him an insanely good deal bro
reminds me of someone
no idea really I don't recognize him at
all 3.3 million followers on Instagram
never heard of this guy before today I
mean really it was this podcast because
he was the main host him and Kyle that's
why he really took off yeah that's
probably where you've seen it start yeah
that's probably rip a dart that's
interesting because I've I've caught
clips of their oh you know what maybe I
that he was the guy okay I wonder how
they set that up
anyway the details is pretty interesting
so the host
Bob menery Bob left the podcast in June
and called out net nelk for slitting his
throat with the way they treated his
departure and claimed they owed him
thousands of dollars
in fact he was talking so much smack
where did he say these things by the way
it was a viral Tick Tock is where it
started which has been erased you can't
find a backup no we we looked before the
show me and Zach we couldn't find it
um and even the articles that were
discussing it didn't have a backup
either so
they're all linking to the original
there's got to be there's I mean I'm
sure yes I'm sure there is somewhere we
got this right before the show but I
mean
if anyone has this send it my way five
percent means everything
yeah so
um yeah this this just developed I was
on tick tock
this morning
before work and I saw Kyle here A friend
of the show
putting out this super serious drama
video and like
I've never seen him address [__] like
this he even says that in the video and
I was like I don't know if this is a bit
I don't know
what's going on
but he's totally serious and it's
actually quite juicy okay so I'll I
guess I'll just watch this one first all
right guys you guys know I don't do the
back and forth straight on thank you for
the gifted uh uh uh Faye plays thank you
that you did on Instagram I don't do the
social media drama [__] that's seriously
not my thing but with all the [__] that
Bob has been lying about on social media
he's pretty much backed me into a corner
now did you find it Abby yeah so we did
find this one I believe this is it I
mean it just wasn't 100 I think this is
the one yeah curious I thought they
owned it who's the shahidis yeah that is
an interesting detail I thought Kyle was
like the main there's four guys the big
Kuba yeah but like Kyle like owns it
right I think so I mean he's not like
the soul owner but he's one of the
owners
hmm who's the farigas Shahidi is a video
game developer
what an American businessman manager and
president of full sent milk boys and
happy Dad oh okay okay so they've got a
big guy at the finance here his brother
Sam Shahidi so the Shahidi
Shahidi version of that name Shahidi is
um it's Arab I believe ghosts of Sashimi
it means beggar in Arabic
so I don't know but also side note I've
never seen a young person do this I've
only seen older Middle Eastern men be
like [__]
he always puts his finger up on these
yeah making a point so what what's your
snap judgment on that video you look
like super hard to tell because I don't
know either one of them right I only the
recent story that I know is Steve will
yank it that's as far as I know stuff a
dog yeah so kind of hard to tell well we
haven't really watched this guy's video
so his wasn't in response to that one
so here's Kyle one of the owners uh
this guy has not jerked off a dog that I
know of just to clarify Kyle is is the
David dobrik of nelk if that helps put
into perspective for people there is the
Puppet Master he's the Don he's he's the
face of the of the Enterprise so let's
watch his video yeah
and just to clarify when I talk about
Nel cast members I need to clarify have
they or have they not jerked off a dog
right right and he as far as we know has
not jerked off
all right guys you guys know I don't do
the back and forth [__] on Instagram I
don't do the social media drama [__]
that's seriously not my thing but with
all the [__] that Bob has been lying
about on social media he's pretty much
backed me into a corner now uh and
attacking something that I've built for
10 [__] years poured my Blood Sweat
and Tears into so okay that I'll back
Kyle up these guys you guys started from
NADA they were just a couple of
pranksters pretty incredible what they
built out of it uh just speaking
logistically no choice I gotta clear
some [__] up so first things first Bob
is saying on social media that we owe
him money that is a complete lie we
don't owe Bob mentary Ascent he's also
saying that he had the worst deal a
terrible deal for the podcast but guys
in the 10 months that he was on the show
he made 1.2 million dollars
1.2 million in 10 months that's good
that's a lot of money What's um what is
that come out to per month 120 000. it's
like yeah 120 000.
or not well no because 10 months yeah
yeah you know what's crazy I know
someone who is making even more than
that
me
that's right just saying I'm falling if
you think what Bob did was crazy play it
right send it I'm gonna show you guys
exactly what his deal was so this is
Bob's deal I typed it out on screen on
Instagram here too also he had not one
but two different lawyers looking he
takes that five percent
all right don't push it too far all
right I got my finger on the tech
difficulties button here extremely
generous if you guys do not understand
I'm gonna pull it up here
so he got 30 of the ad revenue of the
show he never owned it he always says he
owns it he never had ownership of the
show on top of that he had 7.5 K an
episode usually around 30k a month if
that's four episodes
50 of the podcast merch which is insane
first class flights hotels
Transportation all covered by us the
production the staff and the equipment
that's a really good deal all covered by
dude no expenses everything production
wise was covered by milk all Bob had to
do was show up day two sounds so
familiar yeah but also all that plus 30
of all the YouTubers that is an insanely
[__] generous deal almost as insane
as the one I gave
um
five percent means everything
no that one that one is super generous
like they must have thought the world of
this guy though on the other hand to
give that insane of a deal I don't know
anything about him I guess maybe he did
bring a lot to the show I was seeing uh
I think the reason no one in here was
familiar is because he was primarily a
sports influencer which uh not exactly
yeah Sports set of people here for the
most part which is an interesting
vertical because they're very much like
bro stuff yeah it makes sense definitely
makes sense
yeah 50 of merch is insane I mean that
whole deal is like it couldn't be more
gracious in my opinion no yeah for
somebody that it sounds like he just
needs to show up basically they do
everything it's their show it's their
yeah
don't say anything I'm just sitting
wrong but yeah so far um
Team Kyle yeah we love Kyle Kyle I speak
I am in in big trouble I'm so far now to
be in big trouble
so far no
um tonsil stones are flying out that's
true he's also well hydrated we love
that literally drinking that happy Dad
after we rip the darts I don't know that
happy Dad is hydrating but
he's maybe wet your mouth during them
I'm just spitting facts you know I
personally you've taken zero percent of
any of the podcast earnings anything
that I've technically made has gone
right back into the show paying for the
staff paying for the production paying
for the travel but Bob's 1.2 million on
top of that
the opportunity to join the full sun
team and to get exposure obviously from
you guys from the craziest [__] fan
base on the internet that I don't like
as an argument you don't pay people with
exposure you didn't have to say that you
know I mean like generous the insane the
deal is enough yeah you know because
because clearly you wouldn't pay him
that much if he didn't bring something
to the table too you know yeah you know
give me a break here
uh we got a thank you for the gifted
from rabid rat dad
with Peach and love I haven't heard a
word you've said for the last hour and a
half because I just been staring at ELO
the whole time respectively
your thoughts Ela thank you thank you
don't play that music for rabid rat dad
me too I have a preview here
here we go back to Kyle
that's priceless like so many doors were
opened up for him and the amount of huge
brand deals that he got and did on his
Instagram because of this like it's
insane thing I want to talk about is Bob
saying that he built the show he got all
the guests uh I will give credit to Bob
he got some fire ass guests but the vast
majority of guests were gotten by team
full send and he also took credit from
Dana White for getting Donald Trump all
right so I'm gonna make a next slide I'm
gonna put who got which guess too lazy
to say it out loud
yes so this is interesting I guess he's
complaining that he got all the guests
like [__]
here it is
uh shout out Dana White
Donald Trump just one and that's all it
takes
I smoke marijuana so I don't beat my
wife and children
all right that's Dana White
I mean listen this is I gotta say in
defense of Bob again you're downplaying
his achievements here that's one guy
versus a whole team that's a good amount
of guess like Shaq gamble is very
important like Candace on I mean
whatever Antonio Brown a b Bob gave us a
great Shaq sound bites keep me out oh
don't leave me from this conversation oh
wow well credit for that that's true
yeah so I'm just saying you know a lot
of the ones that full sent God are kind
of obvious ones that like I think any
Big Show could easily pull like Paulie d
Airy V
Jake Paul you know what I'm saying
um
he's been on a lot of shows
Kodak Black Logan Paul okay they I mean
whatever I don't know just saying
honestly like I considered Bob one of my
best friends so I still have enough
respect for him where I'm not gonna be
pouring out personal details on social
media
um but you guys see how he is on social
media and behind the scenes his behavior
became like completely uncontrollable
and you know like I'm all about the work
hard play hard [__] no one is more than
me but
my thing is when it affects the team and
the staff and the operation and just
full send as a whole
that's when I personally gotta draw the
line and like make a tough decision so
for months and months and months I'm
trying to figure this out crazy bro
don't say anything but I completely
agree with him I just said crazy bro not
very full scent of him though to not
allow that guy to just have a rampage on
his employees
half sander
hi happy I'm working with him one-on-one
I'm working with his manager his manager
is trying to work with him nothing's
working and eventually he came to me
with a brand new deal and it was the day
before the game episode and he said Kyle
you have 24 hours to sign this brand new
deal or I'm not showing up to the game
tomorrow
and I said what the [__] bob that's not
realistic you coming to me with a new
deal and expecting me to sign it in 24
hours that's not enough time I said come
to the game episode tomorrow let's crush
the episode and you have my word me and
you one-on-one will sit down we'll
figure it out we will come to some sort
of solution like you're my boy Bob like
we can figure this out and I beg with
them and I pleaded with them and he
didn't show up he missed the game
episode
and instead of showing up he just took
to social media so quick and just
started posting [__] about me just
blasting me posting lies and to me right
there like that was the final straw like
I felt so taken advantage of and
disrespected for someone that was
supposed to be my friend like a friend
doesn't go to social media no matter
what to blast you like that speak them
to my soul Kyle and I'll be honest that
actually really hurt me yeah I did that
to me so yeah guys that's pretty much it
after that I was like you know what it's
time to part ways uh and this is gonna
be the last time I talk about this by
the way you're gonna see Bob talk about
this for months and months and months
and months so enjoy that I'm getting
back to work I got [__] to do I got
videos to film
um and that's it thank you guys love you
I got sentence to fulfill
five percent
yo that man is speaking directly to my
heart and soul
it's crazy
I've made fun of Kyle a lot but that was
a pretty good uh I think I like the
video he shows that he's actually a
serious business owner responsible
agreed totally yeah 21 Savage is
basically like my spirit animal and [__]
yeah I like seeing this side of Kyle it
makes it gives me more respect I do
wonder what he thinks about jerking off
a dog I'm gonna send it
it's a concept it's a full sand moment
um golf Donnie yeah so Kyle shout out uh
this is uh we're calling you wild today
so shout out why while
didn't he have like a
decent take in the video we watched
yesterday too or something yeah he was
pretty nice when uh
Bradley was saying that oh I can't
believe that uh he said Hassan and H3
were
creating this ridiculous story that
Steve jerked off his dog
and um
Kyle said something like oh it's a H3 he
just talks about everything like he was
you know I mean he was kind of sweet
about it yeah yeah I've always you know
been a milk fan you know oh yeah
I defended them in the content Court man
I'm a full slander oh yeah that's right
you were wearing a jacket that a friend
bought for you right right yeah
buddy I've always been a supporter you
know yeah that was really good to be
your first message I don't know where my
Bass Pro Shop hat is but I'm gonna get
another one it's floating around here
somewhere I just don't get why would
um like back to that story of the dog
if it's a joke why won't you make it
clear that it's a joke like where is the
humor bro yeah
my thing that I was saying is like why
would you want anyone to believe that
you jerked off your dog because he never
goes I'm kidding he never goes haha just
kidding isn't that crazy nothing funny
about this story
it's Donnie well well not in the way not
in the way that they would want I mean
yes
but my what I liked about it was like
every comment and these are their fans
was like bro he he was not good
by the way
um my cousin told me that Bob was
replaced by Bradley as the new host
Bradley is Bob's replacement I see
I know anything about Bob but you know
from what I know about Bradley and again
is Bradley the one he's the biggest no
that's Steve right Steve we'll do it is
his channel just got banned he's like
you yeah yeah I think for gambling okay
because he kept promoting steak and I
think YouTube yeah that was that's
speculation but it won't make sense
anyway
but actually Bradley does seem like a
nice guy I'll be honest he does seem
like a nice guy he's just a little bit
of a meathead and but that's fine
obviously but a nice time I mean the
song's a meathead I love his son what
he's the guy with the nice thighs big
ass thighs bro he could smash my head
like a watermelon in those the vibe
right now the son always loses Focus
whenever he's on screen oh he's doing
leftovers
yes so sending I guess uh love to the
nelk boys here today yo can you put on
AstroWorld
uh wild and Wadley Wadley
first lob Bob lob L [__] LL and you
know we could always pack chews later go
rip some darts you know whatever you're
in the mood for Zach is eager to spark
up that friendship like a fat dart
maybe they could drop by uh the
Troubadour on the 13th of January that's
right yeah live with Troubadour Junior
yeah Bob's gonna show up [__] edit
out yeah he wanted to fight almost at
once
come on man I'll put my one hand behind
my back [__] he's gonna be
spitting all over his neck Kyle actually
put out photos of the contract they
signed
this is interesting
uh Kyle claimed that at one point Bob
threw a new contract at them and decided
to hold out on appearing on the show
again it's like dude you are
overestimating your
ugh
if only I could have continued for
enemies but I know I couldn't
there's magic there
he's he's even more worth I word that
wrong anyway
contingent compensation
not to speak if I speak I am in in big
trouble
in big trouble and I don't want to be in
big trouble during the exclusivity
period artists shall be entitled to
receive 50 of Sears net proceeds in
connection with merchandise
thirty percent of Studios net proceeds
in connection with advertising
and 30 percent of cu's net proceeds in
connection with any third-party sales
net proceeds shall mean the amount of
gross receipts actually received by
Studio connection with the exploration
of merchandising advertising and or
series rights less all fees overhead
distribution fees third-party costs dude
that is that is clear as day and so
generous by the way
and so clearly stated he got the
receipts got the receipts which
what's the Bob guy's deal
I think he's just if I had to guess
based on personal experience
he got way too bit full of himself and
he thought he ran this [__] show and
that he I don't know why he thinks he
deserves more he's already getting
pretty much like as as much as you can
reasonably pay the talent who just shows
up right
you know you know insurance is just not
covering his Adderall anymore man yeah
that guy's bill for Addy bill is crazy
man
so there it is
uh let's move on now to as you guys know
Dad Friends of the show
we've been having some chair drama have
you been following this Eli here we go
so he
he
[Music]
trying to find it
basically he tried to make right after
last time we weren't happy with the
chair
he wanted us to build it for him so he
wanted to do right and he made the chair
himself he dropped it off to present the
The Throne you deserve where is it in
the dock I know that
yeah tell me the number please oh
there's no video or anything
video no okay so Dad made the chair
and this is supposed to be better than
what the um
super awesome guys made
shout out Tits McGee
are you ready so here without further
Ado is Dad's Masterpiece said that he
wanted us to build reminder oh this was
his artistic vision
a chair Fit For A King I suppose
so what are we switching to that camera
you're when you're back to the camera if
you want dude the [__] soda fell off
I mean you drank half of soda uh the
soda fell out Dan is questioning if Dad
drink what is this piece of [__] wait
it's
um
it's Diet Pepsi but then he put a tape
on here saying Max oh wow you know what
that's an old-time fan [__] yeah Pepsi
Max my dude yeah I didn't realize dad
was a uh in Israel we would only timer
Pepsi Max that was our our Coke Zero
back then and for some reason was super
popular there yeah yeah so you want to
get your other chair out of here you're
not going to need that I guess also on
the back Dan there's some sort of button
I'm not sure exactly what it does
[Music]
okay Dad is in the chat demanding that
we fix the top he's saying a piece of it
is broken why the [__] I gotta fix your
chair dude
what the [__] if it broke that's how it
is you know what I mean uh yeah there's
a button that says push and hold
looks like you just duct taped
everything together
so duct tape is sort of Dad's calling
card all right guys
someone push this in case it's poison so
he dropped it off to security we didn't
see it when it first got here so I I
kind of a feeling that
nothing happens dad your [__] is so
broken I think it's supposed to drop the
crown on your head
yeah
that's what I thought uh Magic
maybe sit
right this thing isn't gonna shoot this
thing's not gonna shove a rod up my ass
is it
okay
it's way too short I mean we're sending
we're sending an expert to take a look
he said push the orange human fecal
matter
which orange man this thing's gonna like
explode I'm taking my weight off
there's a sound yeah
yeah is this thing's just such a piece
of [__] I can't troubleshoot your
everything sucks I know I'm not gonna
troubleshoot your damn it come on guys
he's trying shut the [__] up oh [__] him
dude is he such a slap in the [__]
face with this he's not trying yeah how
is he trying guys come on I'm not gonna
troubleshoot his chair live He's my
fellow crater Clash veteran let's let's
show some love
for what love for what exactly what are
we showing left foot
since when do we show love forever
oh [__]
I think it's about oh Ethan's about to
be impaled it looks like what's the
wrong with this thing duct tape it's
actually quite powerful I think the duct
tape
it's getting clear
[Laughter]
oh come on what ah
you put a lot of work into that throw it
in the [__] trash get the [__] out of
here man
all right well I mean
it's not very stable
I will say when he said he's gonna build
you the throne you deserved after was
super mega dropped off this is not what
I imagined whatsoever are you
criticizing Dad I'm some friendly
criticism
all right well this thing is gonna hurt
me or my dog who's
walking around but okay thank you push
and hold the orange Corner yeah I did
push and pull the orange corner you
think I don't know that
wait there is
oh
okay wait it does make a sound
speaker is really tinny
sounds like a [__] Tooth Tunes
toothbrush yeah it sounds like a yak
back from the [__] 90s
was it just the song I know my song dude
yeah I've never heard that one before
Dad
you gotta dance in the chair to test
stability
you're gonna smash it oh boy here we go
watch out
think about your chair dad just want to
point out that is the newest desk we
have in the office all right
sure
[Music]
I'll I'll throw that out for you thanks
for the trash
the duct tape did hold it together
surprisingly I mean that's crazy that's
a duct tape not Dad
I don't know I see that as an insult
making it that trashy total [__] it's
not he's making fun of me yeah he is
it's clearly trying to insult you Tooth
Tunes [__] toothbrush speaker man
it's [__] up he gave me some joke ass
chair
and that's how I treated it
disrespectful
disgusting
and frankly
and that says okay that's it yeah that's
it what are you gonna do
I'll tell you what we put his face on
the wall so the security doesn't let him
in next time says Ethan went too far
shut up
shut your old ass up
I can finally say that to someone who's
older than me
he said This is war Ethan in all caps
uh-oh shut up [__]
I wouldn't be too worried judging by
that shirt yeah War what are you gonna
dance me to death
bring it bro you were you are too mean
you went too far
[Laughter]
for Dad
cry about it you should have made me a
better care bro Poor Dad all right let's
move on thank you Dad uh maybe if you
want to try again and make a better
chair it doesn't suck
uh I'll try it again but just that super
mega for help yeah yeah maybe I asked
Tits McGee next time that guy knows what
he's doing super mega awesome nerd you
may have won the fight but they won the
chair War
all right we got a lot of other stuff
let's see I think just a suggestion
maybe we finished the tier list so that
uh It lines up the last episode
right we have a tier list to do there's
some top of the show stuff uh next time
Ethan mentions the NRA
yeah I could see that happen
happily
and if I could just say to our fellow
foot soldiers I encourage you guys to
please make memes okay love calls me
late at night it's really sad I'm like
what's wrong love he's like people
aren't just they're not making memes
like they used to it's true dude
yeah wait are you ready to know what it
used to be are you serious lately I've
been on there I'm like the red is like
slapping hard like there's so many great
memes lately there's a couple Champions
Champion for the memes on there Ethan
Dahmer I told you we will watch Howie's
prolapse anus Tick Tock then you can
leave it's pretty that's a good one
that's awesome and then yeah
yeah we need more though we need more
Hassan has like 20 memes a day I need
five five a week check out this fresh
meme this is like literally the newest
post on the Reddit right now is that the
one I'm looking at oh I don't know no it
says I trained in AI to show how Ethan
would look like if he went on a hike
with Philly D I don't want to look like
that frankly no that's not you yeah so
no hiking for me
this one is wow that is Ryan Kavanaugh I
literally sorted by noon that was the
first getting bradded
that is very vulgar
usually they're dressed when they do
that Meme this dressing
thank you you can think
announcement posts thank you
uh
I thought the nightmare blunt rotation
this one cracked me up dude I didn't
realize Keem was so
what I'm I can't I guess I can't comment
on his looks and stuff but he saw
whatever that is
Buffalo
yeah
that is a nightmare Dawson yes Shane
Lucy came and Adam 22. that's pretty
wild eh I changed the odd one out there
why is Shane there yeah I don't know
I felt that no like that's just based on
what I have no idea how these four came
together but
this is around the time of fousey's uh
Drake concert featuring not Drake
what's that got to do with fousey or I
mean chain
I'm not sure keemstar was making the
documentary at the time Shane was the
documentary guy I think Shane was
talking about I don't know if he was
gonna make a documentary about it but I
I vaguely remember this interview
here's another one I told you we will
watch History Podcast then you can leave
we will never let Ethan forget about his
hike with Philly D and you got that on
the schedule yet you know uh we're we're
working on it there's a lots of Lina why
don't you um why don't you help set that
up actually I'll give you Philly's um
I'll give you his phone number actually
and uh you can get that get that on the
boat but the schedule this week are you
free this weekend
it's been pretty full right what are you
what are you doing tomorrow it is busy
this weekend what are you doing after
the show today
I've been pretty on my calendars all all
I got by the way my live ended I just
pulled up your calendar it looks really
open actually yeah yeah it looks like
you got a lot of time what Nina Lina who
pays the bills I said I said it's pretty
full you know it's okay though we'll
find the time make room for it
absolutely she's so right she's gone
[__] wrong did you not [__] get
what I was throwing out I'm busy Lena
it's your job to back me up
oh apparently Shane was there for an
interview and Adam with Adam 22 and
fousey interrupted and the rest was very
awkward that's even better that he
crashed it with the description of that
YouTube video right today the no jumper
live stream I set out to interview Shane
Dawson but instead fousey showed up and
keemstar showed up then ice Poseidon and
Sam Pepper showed up
Hampton showed up for good measure it
was one of the most insane nights of
live streaming I've ever experienced yes
it was gold that is the meeting of great
minds right there the nightmare blunt
rotation right there yeah
I'd like to blank that room
hang out in that room
uh going on I said
[Music]
the picture of uh
you guys is the nice guy big trouble
yeah
I just said man uh blank I like to blank
that room it could be anything I'd like
to be in that room visit yeah is it not
to speak then not to speak
uh thoughts on the Mario trailer I don't
know if we can watch this they'll
definitely claim us this is just like a
four second clip uh when I initially
uploaded there was no plan yeah so Chris
Pratt is voicing Mario and everybody at
first was like that is so [__] weird
dumb yeah and so the trailer drop
actually visually looks amazing it looks
really really cool but as everyone
expected it's literally just Chris
Pratt's voice as Mario oh it's so
[__] bizarre
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
uh yeah epic there's a little Mario in
there
[Music]
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
he's like half
it's like a half it's a half it's a half
he's half sending Mario's voice it's
almost worse than just not going full so
let's just talk normal yeah but why do
you have to hire Chris [__] Pratt get
a voice actor that knows what they're
doing
this is a profession I mean are they
worried that like without someone like
him the movie won't do as well I don't I
don't think it matters personally as a
consumer I don't give a [__] if Chris
Pratt is voicing Mario or if it's some
guy I never heard of who's a
professional voice actor yeah I don't
care I think that's what they think for
sure like the the one that pissed me off
the most I've talked about in like
Guardians of the Galaxy they have like
Vin Diesel doing the voice of Groot and
I don't even know it's Vin Diesel
why Groot
was this 20 donation it makes sense the
original Mario lore says he's from
Brooklyn that he doesn't have a Brooklyn
accent wait are you serious Mario's from
Brooklyn well yeah I think so yeah but
he is an Italian act hey Bowser I [__]
you up he maybe he migrated to Brooklyn
and then Luigi yeah right was from
Wisconsin but regardless I I don't
follow this uh this comment thank you
for the donation though I'm not gonna
roast you too hard for your twenty
dollars I'll be well yeah we all know he
has an Italian accent that's me Mario is
depicted as a portly plumber who lives
in the fictional land of the Mushroom
Kingdom hmm uh his younger taller
brother with his the television series
and film depicted Mario and Luigi as
originating in Brooklyn New York that
doesn't sound like lore to me
come grab a pack this [__] lives
in the Mushroom Kingdom bro which part
of the worst Seaman located in that is
what I want to know
which which part of the Mushroom Kingdom
can I go get my toes
[Music]
yeah
did you guys look really afraid dude you
should watch each other yeah they'll
claim me but it looks [__] beautiful
that kind of gives me Zelda Vibes with
the aesthetic dude there's like a badass
fight scene with Bowser like sieging a
castle and it looks sick animation's
really good I got super hyped about it I
like Jack Black yeah in front of the
show playing Bowser yeah that's really
cool see that
Charlie day is Luigi one more time here
Chris Chris Pratt ladies and gentlemen
I I hear it though
you come to me
to the Mushroom Kingdom
and you're giving me this [__]
Italian voice
haven't we Italians been through enough
with the amount of Italia phobia today
it's really a shame
that this racial stereotype continues to
survive how you doing it's Luigi here
aliens have been through enough
top this
you guys say that I would be better it's
me Mario
all right here we go yeah the French
version is pretty interesting uh that
sounds really good friends
it's much more like cartoony and yeah
you'd kind of expect the character what
are the French gonna do without Chris
Pratt
hey guys it's me Mario
you might remember me from Parks and Rec
I'm the big goofy guy tons of
personality
uh there it is eh you know what I saw
somebody uh compare his voice to and
once I heard it I kind of can't unhear
it
I think I think I have this time
something yes it's Paulie shorts
Pinocchio I bet you this cost them a lot
less to get when can I leave to be on my
own
my father when can I leave to be on my
own oh holy Shore did Pinocchio's dude
this comes out
wait when does this come out that came
out I think it's out wait what are the
reviews then uh Pinocchio a true story
Pinocchio Pinocchio a true story it's
not a true story
it is very much not a true story
to revisit and go deeper that's the
other other
alongside A-list actor Pauly Shore
friend of the show it's not rated on
Rotten Tomatoes it's on yeah wait why it
doesn't I don't think it came out yet no
it came out in 2021. it's 4 out of 10 on
IMDb 22 of Google users wait I got to
cut you off it says official trailer
2022. I didn't come out in 2021. I I I'm
seeing that as well I think maybe it's
getting a theatrical release after being
on streaming service they know it's
going to be that [__] are you sure this
is the same oh yeah
dude it must not oh it says new release
date in Russia though it's Feb 17 2022.
damn Russians they get everything good
it has one review in March of this year
and it is a bad one Pokemon
Pinocchio no
um I've heard us straight to VHS and
straight to television but I ain't never
heard of straight to Russia
that's gotta be really bad [__] it
started the war
yeah come on we're trying to ease tanks
did not cause a [__] nuclear
Holocaust
make it easy with the Pinocchio huh
there it is
um
let's see okay so let's move on to
the
tier list we were doing a tier list
yesterday Ela yeah
of the best worst juiciest cheaters
if you can pull up the list I can catch
Ela up yeah I'm opening up photoshopper
yeah we have two left three left
actually I didn't get to watch yet the
episode
was it fun though it was fun so far yeah
the list
it came out really good um
do you have the file it's opening right
now okay photoshops yeah taking its damn
time and then all it wants me to log in
Creative Cloud every [__] time
yeah so the three that are left well we
did weights and fish I don't know if you
saw that
do you know about I have heard you
describe the story to me
no I haven't seen anything people were
crazy about this one guy shoved weights
and a fish to win a 30 000 I think we
gotta recap tournament yeah it sounds
also the guy has been cheating for a
long time in fact he won a hundred
thousand dollar oh wow and so this is
pretty serious actually he's being
investigated by the police but the
Fallout was pretty incredible
they're cut they're gutting the fish
[Music]
yeah what was weird he also found fish
fillets in there with the white very odd
stuff so weird
instantly one of my favorite videos yeah
so people really wanted that one to be
asked here there we go we had the Ned
try guy cheating scandal was s cheer
me kissing gravy which I didn't think
should be there about everyone
uh the dream face reveal was that what
was the Scandal because she knows I've
been cheating in the game yeah uh the
chess cheating was a Adam Levine was a
bee okay
and so we have uh three left is that
right okay so we do war zone cheating
poker cheating and I Heart Radio
cheating which will actually be a good
segue into our next segment so we'll do
I Heart Radio last
so let's start with um
the Call of Duty cheating here Nadia
now I don't follow Call of Duty at all
I don't know anything about the scene
but this girl I have seen on my Tick
Tock video I've seen on Twitter
hordes of people talking about this and
accusing her of cheating
and uh I really don't know what to
believe although I have a I feel like I
have a hunch one way
but she's a Call of Duty war zone player
who's going viral within the last few
months with clips
taking off like this trying to make fun
of her being a woman in gaming
which is so obviously a thing you
literally if you just use a if you just
express your voice as a woman on these
games these it's crazy the people that
are on there man I mean here you'll have
an example
[Applause]
dogs are fighting each other
she's good at the game too which I think
will piss people off
really good yeah why does that piss them
off because they're [__] fragile
Jordan Peterson you know why isn't that
that's what they want
you think Beauty yeah
somehow her being good at video games
threatens their masculinity which is so
pathetic I thought it was the opposite I
thought they didn't like when girls
would just like
wear a low cut top it's it's that too
it's everything yeah it's it's all the
whole package first part of this video
was her clip and then this is the Stitch
someone made where they use the same
commentary and put it over her doing
dishes
oh my God can you not shoot me like you
guys are fighting each other
epic so that's the Epic joke that
apparently people actually think is
funny oh my God for some reason but
there it is
so that kind of stuff continues not
longer after many of you start popping
up accusing her of cheating
one of the exposed Channel bad boy
Beeman is reaching Brie Larson
quartering levels of obsession
wow
on the woman
holy [__] man
I yeah it's restraining order time
I honestly don't think you could find
another channel that Praises Brie Larson
as much as me this guy literally put
lying [__] in the thumbnail
dude you need a therapy dude it's crazy
yeah I think misogyny is really exposed
in gaming like really really hardcore
and obviously there's a lot of
respectful King Gamers but there's just
so many [__] pieces of [__] to play
these games
Eddie in our chat said in all caps her
aim when she pulls the pistol out is
evidence enough okay well so Eddie okay
well okay Eddie we hear you we'll check
it out uh we'll see what's up hey guys
love the show been watching since epic
gamer gear I still listen to the podcast
one at the meat packing plan okay
that neat
Donovan
or I mean yeah Donovan what's
interesting with this is that you can
think she's hacking without being like
uh weird about it to be fair like yeah
there's a lot of accusations for like
team the top man for example but there's
never this weird weird like super
cringish hate it's just to her because
she's a woman that makes makes it an
issue in my opinion yeah even if she was
cheating even if she was what the hell
is that to do with you know this is so
true love like it's so true
um it gets so vicious and so needlessly
[__] cruel and disgusting just when
it's a woman and it could have been
anyone else that they suspected by the
way Chris K says uh Carl jobst is a
speedrunning YouTuber put out a video
that says dream didn't know
even though it seems nuts doesn't seem
nuts I'm looking at that sometime
[Music]
um I'll check that out okay Chris
um
yeah so here's an example of some of the
videos we've made about her this is the
guy we just looked at there's a there's
a month in there oh yeah dude
[__] yeah bro
love the lighting dude
God
he's literally shooting us in a basement
like peeing there's snow light he's in a
dark [__] room there I guarantee you
right behind the camera there's like
chains dangling from the ceiling and a
picture of Nadia on the wall
oh yeah I know this type
we're gonna watch Nadia play and real
fast and then we can what's the name
I'll give you fifty dollars to take some
photos
can you play the shows here Downing an
enemy and instead of finishing that
downed player she then decides to try
and shoot somebody who's gliding game
favorite away and as she's doing that
her aim appears to snap directly back to
the down player and it seems extremely
unnatural the behavior and she doesn't
take the shot straight away her aim
snaps back to the player and then she
has a little quick second of shock then
decides to aim back down sights and take
her shots on the down player I'm gonna
run that clip through for you now huh
sounds very suspicious
saw that collection of loot you had in
here
it's a little bit just a little but I
have your name on it the music is like
drowning around dude you're so bad at
making videos this music makes no sense
how little sense can you have to this
it makes your video and borderline
unwatchable dude
like why the elevator free royalty free
like might as well just include the
audio jungle
hahaha
I could make it more audio jungle jungle
Christ
it is go outside here
I got that I got your little pink gun
wait do you something similar to it
that'd be better for sure
no we're not Cliff it was originally
since [__] what bro that's the
Smoking Gun well wait till he slows it
down is he gonna slow it down oh yeah by
somebody claiming it was wall hacks how
did she know there was an enemy out
there but just prior to her calling out
there was somebody in that direction you
can hear the gunshots from that
direction so that has been people but
when I was watching this I saw that snap
she was trying to shoot somebody in the
distance who was gliding in and you can
clearly see here aim having an unnatural
movements to the downed enemy and that
is when she decides to stop adsing has a
little moment to herself and then goes
back in let's watch it again now in slow
motion so you can see just how unnatural
that is do you see it it is
oh
oh look at that amazing aim
whoa miss miss miss miss miss miss
miss miss miss what
[Music]
they're saying that she's using an
Aimbot automatically well what's so
unnatural snap that I'm waiting very
good question
well does anyone here play War Zone
because that yeah we all do we all do
yeah because I'm a gamer I don't see
anything fishy here she just looks like
a girl she's an example you know I gotta
say when I play these games I always
think the people that are really good
are cheating when I watch them they're
so [__] good I can't explain it it
feels really good I just can't like
they're just on another level
bro what was that
here's another one with the most watched
here it looks like let's see he slowed
that down he really thought he was
saying something there I was I've
watched all these videos in the dock and
there's only one that I was like okay
that's a little yeah we did watch one
where we were like that seemed weird
yeah but the vast majority of these are
like bruh this guy's made like 20. yes
if you're uh cheating wouldn't it be
like obvious
to find out
and install it and see what that looks
like when you cheat yeah I mean people
are familiar with what it looks like
when somebody is using one of these
aimbots which is is why they they seem
to um
they seem to think that she's doing it
but um
I don't know to me that's just like
somebody that's above average at the
game I don't know I mean yeah you can
definitely try to hide it you know the
way the pros play yeah it looks
unnatural because they're so good yeah
I've seen love
do a backflip over a bullet once in
fortnite and it was the most amazing
thing I've ever seen all right so yeah
it's just people are really good at it
and we need an analysis of that we need
a slow-mo I was so glad Cameron was
playing with us in salt too because I
legit thought I was tripping I'm like
what the [__] it was unbelievable it was
Neo he was Neo yeah well I think love is
cheating then probably yeah definitely
yeah
but to be fair like hacks usually you
can't see them at all there's people who
hack in like Pro matches and CS go and
stuff
and you won't be able to notice it
whatsoever yeah they they honestly
they're really good at hiding it
and implementing it and avoiding you
know cheat detection stuff so
it is possible by the way shout out to
um
uh uh how the [__] do you say that she
he says Atta CD Star Sports
yeah that's what it is
how does that say that
happy birthday she's turning 21 let's go
21. yo [__] you happy birthday
happy birthday
all right a few things I want to mention
though she I may be getting ahead of
myself but she has played the games on
like uh TSM computers and phase
computers to show that uh that's not not
just on her profile that she's that good
or her home computer
she's sat in other places where they
recorded that's interesting yeah and
watched her play yeah she's obviously
good and also she plays on controller if
I'm not mistaken and controller does
have a level of built-in Aimbot that's
like known
um so yeah she plays a controller
trying to shoot take a look at this clip
now
take a look look closely guys
and and I just want to tell you guys as
stupid and silly as this looks this is a
huge Scandal people [__] hate her
guts I mean we've got some triggered
people in our chat some some epic gamer
they're about to have a gamer moment in
their chat yeah like listen listen guys
it's just I think it's like three or
four of them we're gonna show everything
and make a a informed decision here okay
don't freak out we haven't looked at
everything this is bad it's not as bad
as weights and fish man so let me that's
that okay guys guys guys real quick
let's move on please let's keep watching
I just want to say aim assist not Aimbot
sorry if [__] nerds
thanks bud thanks for that thank you
[Applause]
So In that clip you can stop bro okay
even if you think she cheated you gotta
admit that that was [__] so dumb that
was so dumb sorry he's gonna slow it
down let's see this is one of 20 videos
here he goes
watch closely guys
it's about to go down
this is not exactly weights and fish
smoking guns
oh she's shot through the wall
wait did she kill him when she shot
through the wall I mean the pros can do
that that happens all the time as he
just go
just right no there was no kill there
that looks weird in my opinion but no
I'm not saying she didn't even get the
kill without context yeah
well it's more that the aim is auto
snapping to where an enemy supposedly is
okay wait let me watch that again
I gotta go back more
flung up and then I'm sorry yeah over to
the right it did not look weird it did
not look weird to me I mean if you're
really reading into it and pouring over
everything but I mean it could also just
be she's checking the corner I don't
know dude I gotta mute your music yeah
it's awful
all right well anyway that's not very
compelling he made 20 videos about but
we'll move on there's clips that are
more compelling than that obviously
this one has half a million views
apparently this is a good example of her
cheating so let's see
it's Call of Duty player does not even
know what dolphin diving means
these pathetic streamers are unaware of
a tactic used in previous Call of Duties
triggered by pressing and holding the
stance or prone button while sprinting
what the [__] is this
this is [__] what is this you guys
why did 600 000 people watch this but
didn't she claim she has played older
Call of Duty titles Duty I don't get how
to Dolphin die though oh you just I
don't understand
I don't understand where's the cheating
they're saying she doesn't know how to
dolphin dive even though she claimed to
be she's a fake gamer girl dude uh the
title is disgraced Nadia humiliated at M
uh Modern Warfare to land event
it sounds like a and just snuff
and just to show you the the weird
Obsession look at all of his videos
they're all about her this guy has 80
000 subscribers he probably does not get
a lot
look at the amount of Nadia videos it's
crazy I mean he usually get pulling like
now he exposes herself Nadia humiliated
in public in fact let me sort by popular
and you guys can see Nadia Nadia Nadia
Nadia
this one's phased swag shout out Nadia
Nadia Nadia Nadia Nadia Nadia Nadia
Nadia Jesus man mind your business bro
oh got him take the L [__] there's a
ton of Nadia's sprinkled in here so this
guy's basically made his whole career
bro why you have a little child in here
calling what the [__] this kid's like
seven oh no why do you have a
seven-year-old in your banner freak
that's him call of Shame that's him
and we got you game over with a child
there that is a game [__] over and
then this one has over a million views
tired of talking about Nadia Clips the
day this one was no you're not you're
juicing the [__] out of this dude this
was the one I was referring to that I
was a little okay right yeah I remember
watch this this is this is one that had
us all going that was kind of weird
[Applause]
it's down
this door 80s
the name snaps right to the corner does
this look like Aimbot or natural aim let
me know in the comments
I'm tired see so there was a person
outside that she clearly could see and
she kind of shoots into the corner
because in this game bullets can go
through some materials you can go
through like the walls and stuff
is it possible that that's like a place
where people regularly hang out so I
don't find that weird at all just good
play when she runs into the room she
gets a like pick up action for a weapon
and it covers the corner where you
should people usually sit so she can't
see through the like the action notice
or whatever so she just pre-fires it
that's kind of my understanding that's
classic FPS bro and Counter-Strike could
do that job that does make sense too if
someone's always camping there that's
just good play right and also it doesn't
really match up where where the guy
would be in my opinion that's that's
actually a good question let's let's
look at that let's slow this down Nadia
opens the door
snaps right to the corner does this look
like so she did say that there was
someone there
is that what you guys were talking about
no that's that's what they're claiming
because the guy if you see at the end of
the clip she turns around the corner and
there's a dude out there yeah and before
she goes outside she shoots in that
general direction so they're claiming
the hack that she's using automatically
aimed towards that guy even though she
couldn't see him through the wall but
what love is saying is no that's just
good play mm-hmm right I mean I don't
know anything but for me watching it
just seems like she could just be that
good I yeah that's kind of my impression
if you suspect or you think this is
fishy to accuse someone of hacking
obviously requires straight up weight
and fish level of comfort we need
weights and fish yeah because that's a
huge accusation she's a pro player and
the and the amount of hate she's getting
is [__] gross is every pro pro player
getting accused like that because if
it's so hard to tell how do you know
who's cheating right a lot of people get
the cues but not in this to the system
at all
that's the volume of commentary channels
and stuff making just yeah like we saw
endless amounts of videos that isn't
really something that happens dudes get
accused but they don't get bullied yeah
that's a simple way to say it yeah just
straight up being bullied are there any
uh girl gamers who have talked about
this
I'd be like curious to know if they
think she's cheating
right I don't know how many big
streamers uh play Call of Duty
specifically it's kind of a it's kind of
a sausage fest in the Cod Community
one thing I want to look at here is if
she's shooting in the lips if she is
shooting where he is or not you know
what I mean check it out yeah it doesn't
match up at all
[Music]
so she shoots like pretty far to the
left here
okay and yeah it seems that she shot to
the left of him eh no because no way
it's on him right it was too far left
yeah and the thing is this girl streams
all [__] day so you're like oh yo
here's one second of her 10 hours of
playing
it's ridiculous dude there was actually
one clip that was even more suspicious
than that I've that I've seen floating
around a lot I don't know if you guys
uh have that one I've seen it on Twitter
all the time where it's it's like a
close-up of her of her Crosshair and it
just snaps over real fast it might be in
here let me see if I can
Beauty I'm not sure honestly yeah you
try to find that
she responded about this clip in an
interview let's take a look uh we can we
can watch us through full and then we
can watch it through slow as well and
we're just we're kind of picking the
demo yeah she went on this guy's podcast
and he like confronted her so stupid Oh
I think it's in this one I think he
shows her it okay aim it chair guy has
the other side of the wall
I'm an innocent bystander here what is
with everyone's audio it's like doubling
dude like like what the [__] like can
you time stamp me to the other one maybe
you look for that one wait go to the
very beginning of this clip I think I
feel like
yeah it cut the clip really
let me just watch this bar and then I'll
go back yeah I do want to see
yeah I cut I mean whoever clicked that
cut it right right when I was like going
up I mean I could have had a UE
um I could have just killed like
somebody down there and yeah guys
double
I just want to watch this okay we're up
so again like
all right
I don't know
[Applause]
because to me it looked like you had pre
the left wall yeah
and then and then the chair and then
someone was also on the other side but
I'm no analytics guy here so
anyway he's basically saying I feel like
where she's pre-aiming the guy is on the
right side of the wall which is not
directly free aiming what what
just this shot of this parade dude
[Laughter]
this homie's on his phone drinking a
rock star
no we want double audio man that's the
effect
it looks like at that guy she could have
she could have heard someone upstairs
thought she saw someone pre-fired that
corner and we're not on either side here
we're just trying to figure out okay so
let me go to the other one that I
thought was pretty but this this is the
best they've got this is not enough I
don't give a [__] what you think this is
[__] to go this hard on someone yeah
and then probably a bit too fast-paced
can we also get that good old slow-mo
version as well this is the one I've
seen a lot you see how it jumps over
kind of a Call of Duty moment
as the player you were shooting at that
looks good it looks like the player does
exactly the character moves is that
right right yeah oh yeah I never noticed
that
yeah
that makes it even more actually uh in
favor of the people saying she's hacking
because if the game lags and kind of
puts her back a sec and her aim
instantly locks on him that makes it no
but it looks like right okay that makes
sense you've seen it doesn't it look
like he glitched out too though I don't
know well that's the point yeah that
people are making with this clip love is
saying if that other player lagged and
the game kind of like Snapped him to a
different location and her aim also
snapped along then that looks suspicious
but what isn't the snap Universal like
if there won't they doesn't make sense
the physics that they both move the same
time
about that hmm I've never seen a bug
like that where they both move there's
definitely some desync between the two
players I I that happens sometimes yeah
this is like a frame glitch and I've
seen it multiple times but yeah I mean
first of all it could be cheating but it
could also very well just be a frame
glitch like she says it's not enough to
say yeah
there's like streams I mean there's a
guy who made a tick tock about it saying
that he doesn't cheat and this happens
soon
so yeah
so what what is the frame like for
people who aren't as familiar like
what's her job to explain the bug
now she gotta explain the programming
too to convince you
so like do you know the proper coding
for them can you prove it that this is
like a can you get into the co I have
the source code here can you show me
where this bug is located
also she isn't even like a professional
like Pro Gamer she doesn't play in
tournaments I don't even see why this is
a big issue at all she's just a streamer
that's good so she right she hasn't
participated in like cash tournaments or
anything like that so this guy this
isn't a weights and fish situation oh
you're not sure I don't know for sure
but I I was just saying they that all
these guys could just choose not to
watch her videos oh for sure or stream
yeah yeah what's going on because
honestly like I play Warzone a good
amount but I mean it's like the laggiest
game of all time to be fair okay but I
mean obviously I know we're not getting
scientific here but can this is weird
wait they're not getting scientific
that's crazy
[Laughter]
the Red Solo Cup to the rock star but
something told me
it wasn't science happening here
but okay so there that's honestly the
best evidence you guys have yeah people
people in the chat are really freaking
out that that we're
I'm not sick I'm not saying people
freaking out I'm saying both you guys
tell people in chat were losing just a
handful of people there's both I see a
lot of people saying who cares like
whatever she's doing doesn't seem that
suspicious
the thing is she could be cheating but
yeah there's clearly not enough evidence
to
justify this insane horde of people
causing her life to be hell like come on
the question is how many videos has the
quartering made about her
he must have taken the bait right
he's a little outside of his wheelhouse
but it is it is
a woman on the internet that he can
attack so that's what I'm saying right
he definitely took that opportunity
uh she responded to the accusations
numerous times
she says she says I don't cheat so all
you little boys with the fragile
masculinity that can't accept the woman
is just better it's time you face
reality you are dog [__] queen go off
that's kind of funny and so funny too on
her Tick Tock she's bathing all these
people like super hard oh do you think
I'm hacking go go to my live and like
see my uh cam right now I'm showing my
screen and stuff it's so funny how she's
baiting well and you know what
that's an interesting point that you
make that she's baiting on it because I
was just curious myself how popular she
really was to Warrant this much
attention
and I'm seeing I think this this is her
Nadia on Twitch
did you just have the the handle Nadia
yeah she doesn't go buy anything else
yeah her uh her views are way up in the
last couple months sure so
this may actually be a boon that she's
getting all this attention and at least
another story is by the way look at the
top comment on this tweet it's so good
he goes
Fair however I'm a grown man with kids
and I think you're sus but that's
nothing to do with my ego or fragility
in myself as a man it's because I have
years of experience that was playing FPS
games when you are a nappies crying
laughing emoji look look at his [__]
look at his uh profile oh he okay
it looks fine I thought he was in the
camo or some [__] well you say this but
you're caught with unlocked tools and
that classifies as cheating and they
come with Aimbot and walls so you're a
joke you to lie to us again just like
you said you never played at land but
next day you played and you played how
can we believe a liar a money-hungry
person like you there's this is
definitely a 12 year old people really
take offense to everything don't they
look at this yo let whoa you know how
many followers did she get from what to
what
uh from it looks around 60k to 600 000.
a fairly small game or two a bit a large
one yeah like I mean
a thousand significant but yeah not six
I mean it's 10x 10 extra followers in a
couple months let's go all right to
download Aimbot when I go home
start a controversy that's a problem
you're a man nobody cares
she also made this whole twitch uh dual
stream to tick tock Super Famous because
she she's getting most of her viewers
from like Angry Men on tick tock
it's like rage watching copying her now
yeah pretty smart okay
she turned it into a dub
and actually it's not easy I'm sure
she's having a lot of a hard time too
with all this
directed at her it's very true and even
just like going outside and knowing that
there's like so many people that know
about you yeah and like psycho [__]
freaks all the time
um
what the [__] I didn't see the
quartering making any videos about it
but it just every time I go to his
channel I'm so amazed by his thumbnails
he continues to just the most wild
thumbnails I've ever seen yeah he was
um what the [__] is this rings of power
one holy [__] he did not what look at
this thumbnail
what what
I don't think that's supposed to be
drool my dude wait what's the time what
is this he's a quartering thumbnails
Amazon meltdown after the rings of Power
episode because he's been going hard on
the Lord of the Rings show dumb because
there's a black off
and a woman warrior yeah all right
moving on though Friends of the show
Ninja
actually had a really base take on this
he says I've been around gaming a long
time my two cents on any cheating drama
with video games is without Concrete
Hard proof or evidence
I.E you literally see the weights in the
fish
accusations do nothing but hurt people
and cause divide in the community
there's go ninja not gonna lie super
nervous to drop this video having second
thoughts did this guy drop a video
accusing or something oh no so
I don't know how that got in there
because that's its own little subplot of
its own yeah
okay so whatever anyway a shout out
based Ninja for that yeah ninja is
a great guy he is a great guy man hello
hello hello
this one goes up to ninja hello let's
all do it at once okay ready three two
one Hello
send that to ninja
we love you bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
Ethan Klein the boys over there the crew
the crew so it's Ethan Klein and the
boys over there the crew okay ready
three two one
you sound like a DBZ Fusion
yeah so send that guys please make sure
oh Lord
that one I don't know we could pull off
yeah yeah
wow okay
uh so anyway
uh I so let's rate this one all right
it's a d it's pathetic it's not juicy
it's it's honestly pathetic there's no
like depth to the story the evidence is
pathetic except the misogyny behind it
right it's a d and anyone who's getting
heavily invested in this needs to uh
re-examine their [__] touch grass a
little bit yeah how misogynistic they
were giving it a d putting at the bottom
of the list just gotta say yeah maybe
you're right see maybe it's a c because
she's a girl and we love women yeah we
respect women
by the way thank you for the gifted
Brett
ten gifted thank you brother let's go
Brett brother Brett the gift of
membership is more valuable than ever
because we have a members only podcast
every Tuesday there's one up there now
if you're looking for something to watch
on the weekend besides ABS behind the
scenes which goes up today right you can
also watch our Tuesday
um members only a podcast called see you
next Tuesday five podcasts a week your
drive a week baby it's happened and this
one you want to do it with me where
we'll talk shop about the hey I'd love
to yeah I'll try to make it interesting
for anyone who doesn't actually know Sam
that it's right like a day before
Housewives
Wednesday
yeah but I recorded on Sunday usually
anyway
because I can't I don't have any time
during the week so I kind of just
so so there it is that that's a that's a
d I'm sorry I can't even put it at C
it's a d so I'm gonna propose to you
right now Ethan because of how long
we've been going I do that we
uh
wow that's a clever little thing you did
there
um with all my heart you don't respond I
do to a proposal though
if I said yes you wouldn't have got
there would be no joke you know what I
was going to propose was that you wanted
to talk about the podcast stuff and then
that ties in with this I heard cheating
thing I don't think we'll have time for
the poker one I think we should skip
that and get right into the podcast
because we've been going for two hours
and 40 minutes okay let's skip the poker
one that one's not that [__] it's not
that good well put Nadia D we'll put the
Pokemon at Sea it's really not that
interesting
the podcast one is super interesting
um let's see so this one got me so
freaking pit oh we had the Kanye whole
Kanye thing too
Kanye West fashion show where he went
out with the white lives matter
let's do a poll here let's let the
people decide
um well the Kanye stuff is pretty
My Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy what
so do you guys want the uh podcasters
are cheating us
also there's this [__] article in
The Hollywood Reporter that just came
out called the 40 most powerful people
in podcasting including everybody you
never [__] heard of and your boy
being snubbed again
perpetually again I got shedied again
you guys shedied again I mean a lot of
them a lot of the people here are
obviously big and and deserving but like
why do people snub me I deserve my
recognition it's because you're a
Maverick dude Logan calls himself a
Maverick you're an actual Maverick you
don't play the game I get more views
than Conan it's not about views it's
about playing the game well it fell off
dude hard no come on I like Conan too
also you want to talk about powerful
people in podcasting I'm I'm being sued
by Ryan Cavanaugh bro I'm setting the
precedent for free speech how about that
for some respect [__] who wrote this
episode yeah I know I'm sorry don't look
into who wrote this why no that's I I
didn't mean it like that who wrote this
where do they live yeah no no not like
that don't do that
just a figure of speech so do you guys
want the podcasting
um
drama or do you guys want the Kanye West
drama let's vote drama you ain't got the
answer swag drama
actually does have the answers I don't
know if you guys saw that he does oh
that was a big moment Kanye said that
sway was right sway had the answers
Giovanni says thank you to Dan he was
sneezing yesterday and right after Dan
said bless you thank you
there it is you're welcome
oh wow it's closer than I thought it'd
be close yeah go ahead guys uh get your
votes in now
podcasting drama or Kanye right yeah one
second there's our early winner that I
did not expect don't be honest
uh okay you can do it now I really
thought this was gonna go the way of
Kanye but
cross-casting drama isn't a strong
strong yeah it's a strong lead I think
that I think they have it yeah I think
we can call it
thank you for the gifted one-thirds damn
uh a frequent gifter thank you Sam once
thirds of this
Sam
this damn Sam
[Music]
what the [__] is Sam who is Sam I've
never heard of her uh that's got to be
one of the dumbest things the stupidest
moments of my life
are people saying bad pull that was the
most straightforward pool you could
possibly imagine all right podcasting
drama is great cool I thought it would
be Kanye [__] it let's finish this tier
list great poll see Ian thinks he's a
grateful okay so um let's see where do I
begin here so podcast it came out
an article in Bloomberg
that I Heart Radio which is one of the
big podcasting uh conglomerates there's
their production company right they put
out a bunch of podcasts you know they
like they're one of these Breakfast Club
right or isn't that a radio what does
iHeartRadio do yeah no it's the same
company it's their podcasting arm and
yes I heard radio is
um they're sort of I think they're the
biggest player in the game they used to
be uh was a Clear Channel
um anyways they they own almost all of
the [__] radio stations that exist in
the major markets okay so it turns out
they've been buying millions of
listeners fake listeners to game the
head the the leaderboard
by putting ads in mobile games players
in mobile games trigger downloads of
shows no one may be hearing apparently
it's a pretty sneaky
way they're doing this
it every time a player Taps on one of
these fleeting in-game ads and wins some
virtual loot yeah a podcast episodes
begins downloading on their device the
podcast company in turn can claim the
viewer as a new listener to this program
and add another coveted download to its
overall Talent that's crazy and here I
am
putting nothing but Blood Sweat and
Tears
[Music]
and lots and lots of come on Ryan
Cavanaugh's face sorry
um buckets
sorry pocket loads I take it back if I
could
um and you know
here we are working our asses off for
that number 12 spot
all legit man
thank you that's the war horn right
there baby blow it blow it
[Music]
you know what that is that's a marching
beat I got my bayonet in hand
can I get a warmer I it's
or heart
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're going to war folks because we're
number 12. what's our real number
because we're not buying views we're
earning views in the marketplace of
ideas what is real life you know
absolutely good question
good [__] questions
[Music]
pisses me off dude
oh we got a video of it this is super
interesting check this out
so this is um
Subway Surfer super popular game you
probably even played that it's one of
the top games oh I always play it on
flights and stuff six actively managed
ETFs powered by Capital group and
everything behind it explore what's
behind us ban the barricades
this is it you just get like a little no
it's gonna load of six actively managed
ETFs is here powered by Capital group
and everything behind it
TFS at capitalgroup.com
ETFs American Funds distributors
zinc member finra what if you were
so
okay
here's the game
right so to be clear what we're seeing I
guess that was it I was confusing with
the other clip but this was a person
playing this game and then they got that
ad
which a lot of games when you don't like
pay the the micro transactions or
whatever that's like how you can get
around that is it'll just play ads
instead but this ad that you're hearing
is an integrated ad in the middle of a
podcast so it sounds like it's just like
a natural ad but this is actually a
snippet from the middle of somebody's
podcast and so playing this ad is giving
that podcast a view that is Shady it's
very very also yeah it plays the ad
from the podcast which is actually even
more shady because they have tracking
capabilities on these uh audio things
like these big shows we used to do this
where you put in like a tracking cookie
in your s RSS feed and they can tell the
retention on the ad read and so this is
going to spike that up big time it makes
no sense if you looked at the data man
the barricades man the barricades
um the practice allows networks to amass
downloads quickly by tapping into a well
of video game users but also calls in a
question the legitimacy
deepsea and anti-fraud detection company
published a research paper revealing how
the practice harnesses Gamers attention
one referenced in deep seas page is a
Subway Surfer as we just saw it's been
downloaded three billion times since its
debut in 2012. over a period of two
weeks in August Bloomberg found that
multiple Publishers using the game to
rack up podcast downloads including New
York Post Independent podcaster Scott
savlov calling you out by name sad love
you're busted you're busted dude and I
heart
yo Scott you just got [__]
yo who's I actually don't know who that
is but I'm gonna google him well let's
see if he's on The Hollywood Reporter
list actually
God you [__] good we got you
we got you
who's even watching this [__] Scott
ladies and gentlemen we got him the path
here podcast and ain't no path that goes
here other than [__] Subway Surfer a
show about the decision and choices
celebrities have made doing their path
along success new week
um oh that's on YouTube let's see if he
has any actually big episodes
this one has 60 000. he has 600 Subs yo
they're really calling out this guy this
guy he barely exists
hey why are you going after poor Scott
this man doesn't exist
look at this is his whole 50
000 views isn't terrible that's well
that's just bad it's a small small
podcast though maybe he maybe he's well
connected because he's got Charlie day
right
damn dude
the potash twins this reminds me of like
Jay Shetty because like you get to guess
like that too
Jay [__] enemy so so [__] Scott we
gone to you uh yeah drums please
the podcast networks that are actively
mining downloads in the mobile game
Space are doing so through a company
called Joan group
Corey weiner weiner CEO of June group
said the company specializes making
consumers aware of products websites and
podcasts by placing its ads in over 1
000 mobile apps that collectively reach
100 million unique viewers is it
possible that they just went to this
[__] up Marketing Group and then
they're doing it and don't tell them
probably not
um they probably know possible I think
no I don't think they probably they
probably don't know the specifics of it
um
I don't know I've worked with a lot of
marketing companies and they usually are
like we have this really incredible way
of generating maybe maybe they lie to
them I don't know or are not I I think
they wouldn't outline right lie but they
would be vague enough
and just flash the results right right
you know what I mean just be like we get
results if you if you sign with us and
pay us we will get you lots of views on
your show and not really like get into
the specifics because they need to like
link
a specific spot
I don't know whatever who cares thank
you bucket load for the 100 gifted he
did 50 twice that's our Saudi Prince out
there and
uh Ukraine or did he do twice whatever
he's the man love you the bathroom again
that's okay I get it lots of gamer
Gamers up the gamer says goes right
through you dude I've used the bathroom
like eight times today
yeah the starting rate first 20 second
ad is 27 per thousand page view so to
buy a million views it would cost them
twenty seven thousand dollars
but a million views like like Bonafide
downloads and Views is a lot yeah when
you're on the chart that's like put you
at the top
yes indeed you know but 39 million
shares of safe moves yeah so
I guess it's a good deal I don't know
seems expensive to me but
it's just mind-blowing to me that I
heart is doing this because like I said
I mean they they are a huge huge
conglomerate they own almost every radio
station in the country and
um
for them to
like I was saying earlier
people like or boy Scott there probably
didn't really fully understand but I
heart they knew what they were
definitely yeah
I can see it's just like desperate times
the views are going down on Big Shows
they've got big advertisement buys on it
and they got to keep the numbers up to
keep these huge brand deals uh that I
guess that makes sense to me if they're
really uh
unscrupulous is definitely not ethical
it says the company has shut out more
than 10 million dollars to gain
approximately 6 million unique visitors
per month through these ads since 2018
so we've been doing this for a while
the impact can see be seen publicly
on charts from charitable
marketing company owned by Spotify where
mind you oh well this is just
this is just that like audio downloads
right
this is uh yeah just about audio
downloads and
wait you see us on here where is it
where does it say us
oh this is our rating this is our rating
yeah
so what's the one on the top
on chartable
I think it's Joe Rogan no but there's
two different Windows here what does it
mean
oh it's because Apple does their
analytics differently so that's like if
you're using Apple podcast and then the
other one is everybody other than Apple
podcast is
[Music]
opened the fridge and I saw the dude the
bull penis it is offensive disgusting
yeah I have to get rid of that it's like
aggressive
I hate it so much disgusting I said the
other day winked at me
oh no because I open the fridge I felt
it
so on Apple podcast just on the audio
actually I'm not mad about it I mean
[__] 100 good 16 Canada 70 in Australia
yeah I mean the vast majority of our
views are on YouTube 95 yeah so that's
that's nice
but charitable has got us even lower
because they are supporting [__]
[__] you
we're number 17 according to Radar
Online [__] we're dropping because we
were 17. what happened Radar Online oh
wait right this is us
12. we dropped from 12. we're now the
number 17 podcast what are we gonna do
about it
Subway Surfer
yeah baby Lucian but this one's by
survey so that actually wouldn't help us
this is the legit right that's why this
one is more reliable uh I can't help but
notice something I've been thinking
about it but maybe you want to you want
to say something then first
you go Eula I want to hear what you're
saying I when I look at this I really
wonder if we gotta change the name of
our show and I know that it's a big
thing but if you look at all of them
it's either like it says something or
it's a name yeah I agree but the H3
podcast doesn't say anything they all
have like slick branding a good name
ours looks kind of dumb in comparison HD
podcast it doesn't really I mean I never
really expected this podcast to be
topping any charts or anything I think
it's more of maybe not piss off a big
fan base every episode and we have a new
fan base every episode that we piss off
I I gotta say I think it's the other way
around H3 everyone knows yeah I I'm yeah
it's like so Global kind of like the
[__] hour or something
yeah it's hard to change it though
everyone's saying no
let's do a poll yeah no one's gonna like
it but sometimes all right the people
don't know what they want yes they don't
know what we know that's true let's do a
poll I'm just curious karaoke with the
sometimes you know Facebook will pull a
change on you that you hate and then a
week later you're like this is I already
forgot what it was before
we'll have to call it the poop eating
and [__] smelling [__] fest top of the
charts right there
shit-eating gobbling
scissor time
this might be the one most one-sided
pole ever I'm guessing yeah I'm I'm 100
it's not it's it's definitely it's
definitely polarized uh towards no but
it's not the most oh wait it's actually
getting even it's 25 yes that I'd say
think about it
let it simmer everyone who's saying yes
is a new fan I think
just saying and that says a lot doesn't
it listen to them 26 L's
rebrandt we should call it the prolapse
hour
look at number 15 stuff you should know
oh that I Heart Radio
I was gonna say that's one of the ones
there's actually a few yeah here's
another one Breakfast Club I Heart Radio
oh so they were hard okay I wasn't wrong
no yeah you were right um number six
number two crime Junkie perfect name why
is impulsive number six that's so
[__] ridiculous I'm Paul SIV that's a
good name I am pulsive
dude there's no [__] shot this
podcast should be number six The Joe
Rogan Experience like at least it's like
his name
um so you understand that it says Logan
Paul in it
this one says my favorite murder with
Karen cliff griel and Georgia big day
anything and goes with Emma
maybe she just be the Ethan Klein show
you know
everybody I have great name recognition
everybody loves feels super happy when
they see my name
oh thank God pull up the Edison one
you know what that one might
I think Sean I think might be an old one
because I'm on their website right now
and the most recent
ranking that they released uh we're at
we're at 12 it looks like oh give me
that bro
yeah
we're at 12. yeah this is it this is the
most recent one yeah
yo our heart radio just busted a new one
ahead of us drama queens
hold on let me
where are we we are 12 here oh no I lied
I found the one that that okay yeah that
that is the most up-to-date one the one
that you don't like sorry [__] [__] it
was buried a little bit [__] drama
queens is the old cast of One Tree Hill
so they have a lot going you know who
keeps they're talking they re-watch the
show that has such a big family man [__]
them darn dang it what do you guys think
about the Ethan Klein show
well
I don't hate it at the my problem
is that I feel like there's so much more
to the show but then it's like
the H3 podcast with Ethan Klein
possible simple easy change gaffs
podcast
the boys and the crew over here how
about time
well I hear cam thank you at least for
pointing this out
even though we're lower on this one
where are we 24 24. oh he's ahead of us
[__] right above Conan
put impulsives at 21 that's just some
[__] that can't that can't keep
going like that I'm 21. [__] you you
guys need to watch harder
why do you have a sound bite for 21. I
know that's so funny 21 [__] you 21.
that's so true
yo you guys need to watch harder
come on
listen nobody's gonna want this name
change
nobody wants change
I see people suggesting and if you want
your name in there H3 podcast with Ethan
Klein or something like that I think is
a better Direction small change that you
might as well try Yeah we actually don't
need to change the brand yeah anything
you can just don't need to do anything
it'll start showing like that right I
think that's a start
because they were showing the roofs as
our production company and so we're like
yo you gotta right I love the roots but
they're not producing this bug well it's
not it's just incorrect they're not a
production company
well I don't know if they produce other
podcasts they sure as hell don't produce
ours okay yeah in relation to us they're
not
let's call it uh Ethan Klein and the
boys over there
and the boys but then it sounds like all
like possible yes I'm cool with just
doing H3 podcasts with Ethan Klein well
I'm curious why why does why does this
say impulsive with Logan Paul because
that's not their YouTube name exactly
because because he's because he's
smarter than we are but his name and
those damn thing so people know what it
is I'm saying it's not their YouTube
name it that's only on the Sharks yeah
we could do that too I think we should
just do that I think it's maybe maybe
that this goes off of what it is on like
um the Audio Apps yeah maybe that's what
you did on those yeah we could easily do
the same thing
so maybe we should email them and just
say h people don't want my name in it
people you really you guys are so
opposed to my name being there who
doesn't want your name louder with Ethan
Klein on on Spotify it says impulsive
with Logan Paul so that makes sense yeah
we gotta go I think I think just put the
name in there so people know what the
[__] it is
[Applause]
okay let's do that it's fine Unleashed
HD podcast with Ethan Klein maybe we
could do a funny title like H3 podcast
with Ethan Klein
and the family
plus special guests and family the
occurring crew it's not the men's and
family you know something crazy like
that
but yeah I like the crew the H3 podcast
with Ethan Klein for like the Audio Apps
and everything I think that people are
suggesting uh the issue podcast with Dan
swordlove
yeah sure
industry podcast with Ela Klein I like
having Ethan's name in their uh guys do
not say that my name needs to be there
because I don't think so I only do
Friday
eight three thin it's too many names but
I don't know look the podcast
whatever
with the clients
top results Ethan Klein oh there's
always karaoke with the client yeah I I
really don't think this changed for SEO
at least from my SEO point of view it
would change anything it's not SEO it's
not as usual it's um name recognition
yes
people still call me H3 which is like
fine but like
I haven't gone by that moniker in years
I do the H3 podcast shut up and your
social medias too I think
we could think about like what would
make a new person click on this you know
from that point of view
nothing would make you click on H3
unless you already know H3
yeah there is some ring name recognition
there but I think not
the name is not very appealing
what about how is Mandel's favorite
podcast
the number one podcast in the world the
number one podcast in the world call it
that I that now that actually I think
may have some weight to it
yeah because we're already up there you
know if if some nobody's not hyperbole
right it kind of sounds ironic though
which I like and it will and now that's
you know talking SEO love you know that
[__] would go bananas because if anyone
wants to find a new podcast and they're
like What's the best podcast me or the
best podcast
ours will come up I think if we change
the name like that that will [__] up the
rankings for a minute because people
when they ask people by survey it'll be
right which one do I say
no I don't think so yeah because they'll
say which podcast do you listen to say
oh H3 podcast and then half will say oh
you don't think they give them options
to pick from
um I think they just ask them like what
podcasts have you been listening to I
don't know how it works
actually
thank you a repulsive with Ethan Klein
thank you man that's a good one
true that wasn't even a donation that
was just a chatter that I thought had a
pretty funny idea somebody uh Mort says
I don't think the name's as bad of an
issue as the Logo put your face on it
the logo gives you no idea
what do we think about that
that to me is a much better Point than
the name thing because I I personally
feel like H3 I mean you said it yourself
just a moment ago people still call you
H3 like if people know who you are they
know you as H3 maybe Ethan Klein by H3
first but the logo just being the
letters H3 I don't know I if you look at
all the other ones Joe Rogan's face is
on there
uh Logan Paul's face is on there Ben
Shapiro's face is on there you know what
I mean people still click that one even
see what he unbelievable I think that
that's a great Point let's let's do a
poll let's say keep the name
but also how many times people ask us
what the [__] is H3 what does it mean
yeah well yeah it isn't yeah
what do you do my favorite is what kind
of podcasts do you do
that's what people ask when they're
people start taking photos and then some
tourists come up to you and they like
they go what kind of podcast do you do
who are you
what's your answer to that when people
ask I'm polite but it's like if you
don't know me why do you care
you know it's a podcast it's a comedy
you can check it out on YouTube yeah
just keep it you can always give my
answer what dold entertainment baby
adult entertainment
it's adult entertainment you don't want
to know yeah you don't want to know can
I be honest real quick I think we have
the most powerful
branding out there of any uh content
creator because there's no one that has
a two digit or number or whatever search
term H three and three all our stuff
comes up there's nothing better I love
it I am so so against this idea I gotta
balance it's the cleanest [__] I'm also
with my other boy well yeah I I'm I'm
more reluctant on the name thing
although having it a subtitle of like
with Ethan Klein or something I don't
think would hurt necessarily do we all
agree that H3 podcast with Ethan Klein
on this chart is fine yes we like it I
think at this moment there's absolutely
no reason not to try that because it's
not it's you're not even changing it
right it's not a huge like overhaul of
anything really
yeah okay so given that and now let's do
a pull what about the the logo yeah
should my face be added to it should
Ethan's face be added to the logo yes or
no yes or no
and they will they love you so they'll
probably say yes right
you know something anybody that doesn't
like you is like no I don't want to see
his [__] face every time I open the
podcast app something I've thought about
for a while I would love for at least
one of the shows if we brought back the
OG music I don't know just Good Vibes
the OG podcast music just saying
entrance music for the live show wait
perhaps I don't even remember the theme
song Maybe on the Tuesday here it is
because we made the new one maybe we
should bring this one back yeah
let's bring it back the new one's great
too though yeah a new one's good maybe
we can mix it up people are missing this
maybe one one for intro one for outro
Zach that's a good idea this one's the
intro Zach
from now on for every episode yeah well
we only
Yeah It's Complicated by the fact that
we only really use it on Wednesdays
well you can start you can start every
podcast with theme music no do you want
to get rid of Jay-Z you also play for
after Dark
yes
ice ice second that kidding me Zach it's
about time we've enjoyed Jay-Z for like
okay maybe two years
yeah just bring it back yeah branding
too just to hear that you know how much
that we worked with somebody on what
about this he had that in all of his
Vlogs it's just yeah you know you know
what someone's watching when you hear it
so uh it seems like people are in favor
of putting my face in so that's
interesting so maybe we could taper just
a little Tinker 40 of our audience of
our own audience is like no I don't want
to see your face in the look I mean I
get it that's why I didn't put I the
amount of people that hate me on the
internet I knew that if I put my [__]
face in that logo a lot of people are
not gonna click it so I'd be like yo
maybe if they don't know what it is and
if it's with me they'll click it no I
don't think that's how it works pretty
sad but yeah
I think if anybody is not clicking on it
it's because they don't know what it is
right
okay let's take her with it a little bit
that's good we're we talking about
something yeah we were talking about our
heart radio Let's uh because we probably
have to wrap up I assume you guys have
to get out of here soon yeah right so
well hold on so uh our heart podcasts
represent more than half of the 10
trending shows every month [__]
cheaters
here's some of their top shows
missing on 911 you have a podcast about
so oh it's done
it's over so I ended in August 2021.
never forget it right but that that's
the point
the last episode was in August 2021 it
was number seven on chartable
that's not out yes that's what I'm
that's what I'm saying is they were
bonding The View so badly that this
podcast that hasn't that's been off the
air for a year was ranking number seven
the gain from that
they're juicing it I mean my juice is
dead maybe it's just overlooked you know
somebody just kept uh paying for ads or
something yeah it could be that
um I heart also maintains the top
position on pod track a monthly podcast
ranker that measures networks audience
and downloads [__] you 35.5 6 million
over 6 billion or that is fake [__]
there you go LL and then there was
another podcasting thing I want to get
to real fast
um
can I just say sorry real quick someone
in chess said uh for the logo add
Ethan's hair slash beanie silhouette on
top of the H3 that's kind of interesting
that seems like a Howie Mandel thing
where it's like he shows the back of his
yeah Mandela is one of the biggest
entertainment entertainers in Hollywood
maybe watches his pockets
heck of a bald head what about what
about like three beanies stacked on top
of each other on top people don't know
what that means that's even more that's
his vague as H3 you got to just show my
face otherwise I might as well just show
the back of my [__] head just so you
don't worry about it if Ben Shapiro can
have his face in his logo that's fair
that is true
now that is one
disliked face absolutely
um well there was what was the other
podcast related thing it was uh for The
Hollywood Reporter article oh yeah we we
talked oh yeah so we kind of covered it
but I mean this this I mean this is
outrageous you guys there's no respect
what do I gotta start juicing My Views
to get some respect over here Hollywood
report made an inaugural podcast
powerless the list features creators for
the most influential shows and
Executives behind them this list is just
another piece of evidence that of the
man trying to keep me down
and some of these dudes on here I'll
just be straight up
they've got like 6 000 Subs didn't you
see one of these guys
first they hear which was the one that
guy that had like six thousand I mean
there he is and I'm tired of Jace
Nemesis Jason has a Facebook podcast
that automatically excludes him from any
list first of all and second of all this
guy keeps winning every damn award
I'm sick of it
um
do you guys know any of these people
Kara Swisher
nope nope L I know Conan Conan we're
ahead of Conan though but it's like
these people I don't know all of them
but it seems to me like maybe they're
just all kind of more in the circles yo
of like mainstream yeah so that they
have agents and PR people yeah they're
like yo how about this guy yo this guy's
name is Sam Sanders he was named best
podcast host by Ambien the sleep
medicine no that can't be what
it actually says the ambes oh the Ambi
funny Ambience top podcast to listen to
as you fall asleep
holy [__] guy Raz who's guy Raz sounds
like a Batman villain guy raps isn't it
from from the show we listened to is
um I recognize it NPR yeah NPR yeah oh
I'm guyra yeah oh he's the guy that goes
hmm I think it might be him or a
different guy but we listen to it
finalists uh New York Times is one of
the most popular podcasters in history
okay yeah I know he's actually good
podcast has a combined monthly audience
of 20 million okay fine Raz
he goes hmm I love the daily manager
[__] but we get more than 20 million a
month
more than that
no now I'm pissed again Raz
Conan O'Brien I mean obviously everyone
loves Conan but
[Music]
just call it spade a spade
I think his podcast been doing pretty
good not it's not above art
on the rankings period he's so powerful
it's like
what and it's like then said you got to
play the game
um
gotta like
you gotta play the game exactly and like
getting the
in the whatever meeting that's the game
Empire professional PR
people it's so stupid because PR people
are such scams it's like you gotta pay
them off just so you can end up on these
dumbass lists and they're so expensive
man we work with pure companies with
like Teddy fresh and it's like some of
them are like twenty thousand dollars a
month legitimately and they do [__]
nothing we tried it we're not
actually doing it we're no longer
working with PR I've tried it so many
times because I think well it's got to
be something to it with Teddy fresh I
tried it with H3 in the past when we're
trying to get guests for the podcast and
these people do nothing
and the payment isn't the same
in August sorry so I know in August we
got 22 million views
oh my God and it's been around that on
average and then going back to March
YouTube uh YouTube yeah on you uh
YouTube March 2021 49 million
we had 49 million dollars starting 48
million yeah that was friend I mean [__]
March 2021 you had to be how else are we
getting 48 million views Yeah Yeah March
2021 40. dude I'm telling you that month
or that whole time period with Frenemies
I think we must have been the most
listened to podcast in the world maybe
more than Joe Rogan maybe I'm not sure
about it but those views were Rogan gets
like 10 to 12 million per view or per
episode
as big as him so they claim
hate to say it
um here's a really interesting one
that's in here and just goes to prove
the point that you got to play the game
to this article was published two days
ago
the game which is several like a week
after the Bloomberg article about these
guys
they literally this isn't even a podcast
they're just saying the I Heart Radio
like CEOs of the podcast I gotta say
something this dude on the right Will
Pearson looks like a Canadian from South
Park
[Laughter]
pull up a photo of a Canadian from South
Park damn get absolutely slaughtered out
here
oh guys shout out to Glennon Doyle the
Christian parenting blogger
look at this dude he's straight up is a
Canadian look at your ass damn
I'm not your friend
this qualifies him
yeah uh shout out to Christian blogger
turned author
we can do hard things
only if you're married you know what I
mean we talk about Christians here
we're just like him we're just like that
I mean call me daddy obviously she's a
huge deal Emma is the Emma's Queen
and uh Jake Brennan obviously I don't
know anything about him but whatever
uh and of course these dudes the daily I
can't hate wait this is the hmm guy
that's the daily guy the other guy is
NPR that's Babar yeah yeah yeah this is
the guy Michael Barbaro yeah Michael
babaro um
looks like you in a different Universe
it looks like the AI generated version
that you thought we had earlier right
where'd they put my face on his body
exactly yeah yeah I think they honestly
swear on on garsh
that's oh yeah that is literally him
that's him
it's this
I trained an AI to show Ethan wait okay
that's a joke
I guess but I don't think people know
who this guy's face is uh people are
saying it's Sam Cedar but it's not even
that's funny these people don't even
know I mean yeah it's not an actual AI
generated it's just funny okay yeah so
wait if you reverse search engine this
is this yeah it's there's more people
that's funny because when I was looking
so that's our guy I thought it was
Photoshop because I was looking at his
neckline and it looked kind of weird
right and I was like Photoshop looks
real yeah so here's the real photo
uh oh my God somebody really got us good
man
here it is
um
it's Jay shetty's team you just got
[__] again it doesn't look real in
this full photo for some reason yo that
is such a [__] awesome once you think
about it as AI generated this is like
his neck seems too slender for the size
of his head
but
am I wrong I mean
that's what I thought I don't know but
that studio is [__] epic dude look at
that sound uh proofing the show is epic
yes it's quiet in there the daily is the
only podcast I listen to daily
you listen to The Daily Mail all right
guys listen uh let's place the the the
podcast cheater
it's not that good honestly I think it's
l tier
right I think I don't know I think it's
interesting that like a company as big
as I Heart Radio is so desperate for
views that they're willing to game the
system it's like weirdly interesting and
boring at the same time yeah I mean it's
not like as juicy as like an affair but
they they are scamming me oh Cam you did
it on the wrong guys the other guy oh
[__] no it's not oh you put it instead
yeah yeah my bad my bad I thought you
were trying to put them next to each
other yeah here dude from I heart change
your profile picture
I've seen people a lot of bees in the
chat rating it that highly yeah I mean
this is an interesting the Sharks
they're boosting this is a national
tragedy that they're robbing grass
what's the grassword Grassroots
grass doesn't have a lot of roots I find
that just odd kind of analogy I mean
Grassroots it has just not a lot of
roots what is the idea of fast food
thing that it has a lot of roots
I guess lots of Blades of grass have
lots of roots but they're very small
roots maybe the point is that lots of
grass roots so it's like that's really
true I think grass grass roots are
fairly deep what get out of here look at
this
they go down they go down there dude
why are you hating on the Grassroots
that is interesting actually but then so
this one is they're pretty short you
know I'm seeing mostly bees and C's
primarily so I'll do a I'll do a b
because it's at a direct attack on our
Institution
okay I think that's fair oh I hear this
is Grassroots the most basic
where'd you put that
oh I deleted it so there's another this
is the most basic level activity for an
organization or the verification why do
you erase because if I find a better one
I was gonna send a better one oh yeah
maybe I just want a microphone goes up
here man I know it doesn't go thanks
thanks yeah like this I just want to
point that out okay is he is he
regularly not no he's no he's great he
was just he was like talking like this
you know got it got it all right well um
listen
it's been a good time it's been a it's
been a great time
thank you for everybody for watching
thank you especially to our members who
I love
I love all of you like my children but
the members uh make it all possible
um love them like your favorite children
maybe we should end with that like the
drums yeah and the marching yeah pretend
I'm [__] St Jude's child cancer and
give me five dollars a month
[__] them kids
a [__] kid God damn it
uh no but thank you guys there's uh bats
coming up there and uh the members
podcast is up there and a big special
one that me and either gonna make on
Tuesday is gonna be a lot of fun uh
thank you mistake for the gifted thank
you everybody had a lot of fun here lots
of laughs had a good time didn't we
pretty good it was okay pretty good
pretty fun it's pretty good okay
cool
it was pretty cool not bad not bad
pretty cool yeah created
yep yep
so uh we'll be back on Monday do we have
anything popping on next week that's
worth mentioning
um
let's see here pretty good we need to
talk about costume ideas
oh our Halloween episode yeah there's um
dude we're planning an epic ghost
hunting Special by the way you guys so
if you guys were a fan of last year's
ghost special
we're coming back with a even hopefully
better one
then we lock down that location
uh no not yet but it's being worked on
we had to I'll tell you after the show
but it it it's super official we're
getting a permit and everything
we always get proper permits and do
everything above board with everything
we shoot Ethan always I don't know why
you would have to specify that right
we are a big respectable
we need a higher PR back
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[__] H3 family real [__]
called H Scott that's funny cold three
cold three I love that
all right have a great weekend everybody
uh see you on Monday
[Music]